I kept you waiting, huh?
Welcome back, Master and Lady!
Oh my god, I don't know what it is.
This, like, title menu music is making me so emotional.
Thank you so much!
Thank you to the five gifted!
And... oh no, am I gonna say your name wrong?
Joao!
Thank you to the five gifted!
Welcome home, boss!
Welcome home!
Oh my god, can we watch the one-hour briefing too?
Uh, I...
Oh, yes, first of all, yes!
Still afraid!
Thanks for the ten gifted!
Thank you!
Thank you for the ten gifted!
Thank you guys!
I want to... Before we start, I wanna kind of...
I guess, go over some stuff.
Because I think maybe some people are like...
Maybe some people are like, I think Mint has played Metal Gear before, so...
What's the deal, yo?
Is she just replaying Metal Gear?
Essentially, the short answer is yes.
The short answer is just yes.
I'm replaying Metal Gear series.
So... But probably for the games, when I played Metal Gear Solid originally, I played the original PlayStation version.
This time I will be playing...
...Integral.
So probably for games like...
For the games, I'll probably be playing Metal Gear Solid.
Maybe like a different version of them.
Thank you guys for all the gifted!
Thank you guys so much!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you!
I really appreciate it!
Integral has Japanese text only for the menus.
Everything else is in English.
So don't worry if you're just like, wait, but it's in Japanese!
Only like the stuff about the weapons and...
You know, the information about like...
The rations...
Stuff like that.
That's only...
But we know what the guns do!
We know what the Nikita missiles do, and the Stinger missiles do!
Yeah, so...
It will be in Japanese, but...
But all the voices are in English.
And everything like that, so...
Gun goes pew-pew.
Oh my gosh!
Thank you!
Send tweet!
Thank you so much for the...
Akasofa, thank you!
Thank you, thank you!
Is it EN dub?
Yes!
It is still EN dub.
Yes, yes, yes.
My most annoyingly Huey voice.
Um, excuse me, boss!
The sneaking suit is in the thumbnail!
Oh gosh!
But...
Essentially...
I really love Metal Gear.
And I just really...
Want to stream it.
Um...
I think I've...
Oh my gosh!
Thank you for the 15 gifted!
Thank you guys for all the gifted!
Thank you so much, Bloodless!
Thank you for the 10 gifted!
Did you know that you can put fake data on the virtual memory card for these versions?
I didn't know that!
I did, I did, I did.
But thank you for the reminder.
Um...
I really just wanted to play Metal Gear.
That's why...
Well, I played Twin Snakes.
Um...
There's actually one Metal Gear game I still haven't played, which is Acid.
So...
But also...
I need to get through the other games to get to Acid.
Um...
Oh, and Ghost Babble.
You're so right.
And Ghost Babble.
But um...
But anyway...
Um...
Uh...
So...
When I...
Think of like my channel...
And like the games that I've played...
Like...
I think of it kind of as like a resume.
Where I'm just like...
This is...
This is my work, right?
It's kind of like...
You know...
How do I say it?
Like if someone were to be like...
What...
What has Mint played?
What does Mint like?
It's kind of...
In that way, I'm like...
Oh yeah...
I can't claim to say that I love Metal Gear so much...
And not have it on my channel.
You know what I mean?
Yeah, like a portfolio!
Yeah, that's a better way to say it.
That's the word I was thinking of.
A portfolio!
And so...
If you're just like...
You know...
I think Mint has already played Metal Gear.
I think she really likes it.
But I also need people who don't know me...
Who come to my channel for the first time...
To also see how much I love Metal Gear.
A.K.A Konami.
Konami, if you're watching...
Hi!
I love Metal Gear!
Please sponsor me!
Thank you!
I'm waiting for Delta!
I'm very patient!
But also, Snake is running out of air in his little Eggie.
Thank you, Ducky.
Thank you for the donut.
But also...
Even though my brain rot for Metal Gear is very great...
I am not a gamer.
So please...
Be patient with me.
There may be times that...
You say...
Mint!
Do this thing instead!
What's wrong with you?
And my brain...
Says no.
So...
Please be patient with me.
Because I'm...
Not a gamer.
And I...
Will mess up and be slow.
Please be patient.
I'm a Vtuber.
You may say things such as...
VTuber!
Get the thermal goggles!
And I say...
No!
Because I am also stubborn.
But we're just here to have a good time.
I'm not doing any sort of challenges or anything like that.
I'm not here to be like...
European extreme.
No kill.
No alerts.
Whatever, whatever.
I'm just here to have a good time.
And relish in my brain rot.
Will you play VR Mission someday?
I would love to!
Because I've actually played...
Um...
Like...
Not VR Missions the game the game.
But like some of the VR Missions.
But...
I do know about like...
The fun...
Um...
Oh my gosh.
Hi, it's me!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
You guys are going so crazy.
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
Um...
What was I saying?
Oh!
Like the fun missions like...
The one with like the giant...
Um...
Genome soldier.
And the one...
My favorite is the...
Um...
Is the...
Uh...
Locked room murder mystery.
Love it.
I love it, love it, love it.
Genola!
Yeah!
The return of Genola.
But yes.
So...
Um...
Yeah, we're just here to have a good time.
I really love Metal Gear.
I really love...
You know...
I love the gameplay of Metal Gear.
But I mostly love the story.
So if you're just like...
God!
She loves Metal Gear so much!
But she's so bad!
It's because...
I'm a sucker for the lore.
But that's okay.
I endure the gaming and the stealth.
So that I can see the characters that I love so much.
But anyway.
So if you're just like...
Man!
What games will Mint be playing of Metal Gear?
Um...
Probably all of them.
Because I want them on my channel.
And also...
I like them.
And yes, I think that includes Five.
Because I'm insane.
Oh God...
So...
I think this will be...
A pretty long journey.
Um...
Of Metal Gear Madness.
But I think we will have...
A fun time.
So...
Let's start!
First on Metal Gear Solid Integral.
And yes!
I'm gonna be playing them as if they are...
As if like...
Not that I'm playing for the first time.
But if someone has never seen Metal Gear before.
I'm not gonna be like...
I'm going to try to avoid spoilers when talking.
And also I'm going to...
Uh...
Watch like all the cutscenes and things like that.
As if we're playing it for the first time.
Um...
So if anybody...
Also...
Has never experienced Metal Gear.
And it's your first time watching.
You can feel like this is a safe place.
Well, hopefully.
Gosh!
Oh my gosh.
Thank you for the...
Thank you guys for the super chats.
And all the gifteds.
I really, really appreciate it.
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Should we do smiley faces in the chat?
You can do it if you see a spoiler.
But don't do it for my sake.
Because, you know, for me it's whatever.
But you can do it if you're just like...
Hey!
Get that spoiler off the screen.
For the new people!
Yeah.
So hopefully we can all respect that.
And remember that for future games as well.
Yeah.
And you know, it's not gonna be...
If you forget, that's okay too.
Don't worry about it.
I'm new.
Are you?
Oh yeah.
You're totally new.
I've never seen your name before.
Sorry.
The dog...
The dog's in.
The dog's in!
Oh.
Okie dokie.
Thanks guys!
Let's do the edit save data first.
Okay.
It did save.
I did test it out earlier.
So...
I guess spoilers, I guess.
Oh wait.
Back.
Cool.
Start the main...
Oh my gosh.
You guys...
You guys want to know what I love so much about...
Look at this.
So...
Wait, how do I go through it?
No.
How do I move through it?
How do I...
Jump the page?
No.
Oh, there we go.
I was like, what the hell?
Guys, look at this.
When I...
Okay, so someone's making a mod that puts my...
Me.
That puts me, Mint Phantom, into the game.
You can play.
It's a mod...
It's a mod swap.
And I was just like, oh my gosh, what if I like, dub over Snake's lines so that, you know...
So you like Tokimeki Memorials.
Oh my gosh, yes.
And like...
Um...
I was like, what if I dub over this...
All the lines.
And I was like, totally serious.
Because I was like, um, the Master Collection has the entire script.
Of the game.
And also...
Of the Codex.
So I was like, it'll be easy.
So, um, I hope you guys are excited for membership dubbing streams for the next couple of months.
I'll probably do it in membership.
So, um...
Yeah.
And then I will just, uh, be recording for days.
Who the hell is Kenneth?
Kenneth!
Kenneth Baker.
I forgot this is...
Just seeing Kenneth not Baker by itself.
Like, Kenneth by itself is just so funny.
Oh, spoilers.
Oh my gosh, there's spoilers here.
You guys, open the menu.
How do I get out of here?
Oh, yes.
Yes.
Kenneth Baker.
Kenneth is just such a funny, like...
Oh, it's Kenneth.
Anyway, okay.
You guys.
We'll see him later.
Um, actually the MGS2 Sneaking Suit is just the suit from MGS1 with the vest and pants swapped out for Tactical Harness.
So close enough to be...
Oh, thank you.
Yeah, I'm just, uh, I'm, uh, in the thumbnail, I'm, um, just a little more naked.
But not Naked Snake.
Unless...
Oh my gosh.
You guys, I think I manifested...
I think I manifested the, um, the MGS2 Figma redo, like, or update.
Because, like, literally the day before...
I was on my PS3 getting ready for Tokyo Jungle, and I was like, oh, I wonder if they still have, like, the icons, and I can buy a Metal Gear icon.
And you know which one I bought?
I bought Metal Gear Solid 2 Snake icon!
Like, I almost bought Paz.
I almost bought Peace Walker Paz, but I was like, no, you know what?
I really like the blue.
I really like the Metal Gear Solid 2 blue.
Now I'm gonna get Snake.
I think I manifested it.
I think I did that.
You're welcome, everybody.
That must be why they released it.
I think so!
Will your MGS mod have the cake?
Of course.
Actually, I think you should ask the...
the boss.
The people, the modelers.
If it isn't Saucy Vito.
I'm late.
No, you're not.
We're just getting started.
Don't worry about it.
Oh my gosh.
Here we go, everybody.
Choo, choo, choo.
Choo,
choo, choo.
Have you ever played Policenauts?
Not yet.
I do know what that little tune is from Policenauts, though, right?
Or was it Snatcher?
It's from one of them.
I can't remember.
Hi, Menzo!
Hello!
Oh!
Hold on.
Wait.
Was it in... No.
Hold on.
Wait.
No, not off.
Hold on.
Return to the menu.
Wait.
How do I do it again?
Oh, shoot.
I forgot to change it to the...
Oh, it's under... Okay.
We have to go to the main menu.
Go to the main menu in the game.
And change it there.
My bad.
Sorry.
I forgot to change it to the subtitles.
I forgot to change the subtitles.
It's because we just went straight into the video.
There we go.
It's just because we went straight into the game, right?
So I was like...
I was like, wait.
I didn't change it.
Okay.
We'll just watch the briefing.
Now.
Now we got it.
Okay.
It's been a long time, Snake.
I should have known you were behind this, Colonel.
That's no way to greet an old war buddy, Snake.
What do you want from me?
I just invited you here so we could have a talk.
Invited?
That's what you call sending armed soldiers after me?
Who's taking care of the dogs?
We're rough with you.
But we've got a serious situation here.
Only you can get us out of it.
I'm retired from Foxhound.
You're not my commander anymore.
And I don't have to take orders from you or anyone else.
You will take these orders.
Without the filter and everything of this picture.
Excuse me.
Who's this?
Dr. Naomi Hunter.
She's chief of Foxhound's medical staff.
Dr. Naomi Hunter!
Are you military?
How's the audio, by the way?
I've been sent here from ATGC.
He looks blonde here.
I know.
That's why a lot of people think he was blonde.
This injection won't hurt a bit.
What's the shot for?
What's wrong?
You don't like shots?
No, I don't!
Snake, listen up.
It all went down five hours ago.
Heavily armed soldiers occupied Shadow Moses Island.
Shadow Moses Island?
Alaska.
What soldiers?
Next generation special forces led by members of unit Foxhound.
They've presented Washington with a single demand.
And they say that if it isn't met, they'll launch a nuclear weapon.
A nuclear weapon?
I'm afraid so.
You see, the island is the site of a secret nuclear weapons disposal facility.
Foxhound hijacking a nuclear weapon?
Now you understand how serious the situation is.
Foxhound.
You'll have two mission objectives.
First, you're to rescue the DARPA chief, Donald Anderson.
The diaper chief!
And the president of Arms Tech, Kenneth Baker.
Kenneth!
They're both being held as hostages.
Those are some heavy duty hostages.
Secondly, you're to investigate whether or not the terrorists have the ability to launch a nuclear strike.
And stop them if they do.
I think they're bluffing.
Questions.
I haven't even said whether I'd accept this mission.
Well, you can make up your mind after you hear more about the situation.
He's like, gosh darn it, president, this isn't what you promised.
Yippee!
Oh, wow.
Well, we can't read it, but that's okay.
We'll just pretend.
Think about the nuclear weapon disposal facility.
The disposal facility includes a hardened underground base.
Even with our most advanced intelligence gathering equipment, we can't tell what's happening inside.
So someone needs to penetrate, gather intelligence, and report back.
Sounds like a spy movie.
What's the insertion method?
Well, an air insertion is impossible.
Not with a storm going on.
We'll approach the disposal facility by sub.
Approach?
Yes, within a few miles of it.
What?
Why is he so surprised?
How else are you going to get there?
You have to approach the place to get there, Snake.
And then?
We'll launch a one-man SDV.
Launch?
Woo!
Only this has no propulsion device of its own.
After the SDV gets as close as it can, dispose of it.
From there on, you'll have to swim.
You want me to swim in sub-zero Alaskan water?
I thought in the one...
That suit represents the latest advances in polythermal technology.
You could, like, move the camera in this angle.
I thought you could move it around, but it's not happening.
I'll instruct you by codec after you reach your target.
As usual, this is a one-man infiltration mission.
Weapons and equipment OSP?
OSP!
This is a top-secret black op.
Don't expect any official support.
There's so much...
technical speak.
Don't expect any support.
This is madness!
I can read that.
Wait!
We have a Taimurimito!
No way!
Uh-oh.
What's the time limit?
24 hours.
They say they'll launch after 24 hours.
It's too soon!
Do they say what the target will be?
So far, they haven't mentioned the target.
When did the countdown start?
Five hours ago.
So I have 19 hours!
Oh my god.
Now we're on two.
Roy Campbell.
Dr. Naomi.
Oh gosh.
I give up.
I can read them individually.
Almost not all of them.
But together, I don't know what the pronunciation...
the reading is at all.
Oh, I can read!
Camera free!
Here we go!
Colonel, who are you speaking for?
Naturally, I'm representing the U.S.
government.
Too low?
So who's in supervisory control of this operation?
The President of the United States.
Which means that the President must be meeting with his top aides in the map room about now, huh?
No, at this point they're still videoconferencing with each other.
If that's a real nuclear warhead, shouldn't they issue a COG?
Not yet.
The Secretary of Defense has operational control and is fully aware of the situation.
After you infiltrate, if you determine they possess nuclear launch capabilities, a COG will be issued.
Well, if they haven't relocated to the nuclear shelter under Mount Washington...
For free?
Camera free?
Feet free?
I suppose there isn't that much reason to worry yet.
Why don't they give him any clothes?
Why is Snake not wearing clothes?
I don't know!
Did they capture him?
Did they, like, kidnap him while he was taking a bath?
I just don't understand.
We need desk jockeys.
We need a nuclear weapons specialist.
Of course.
A nuclear weapons specialist has already been assigned to us.
What is that?
What's conament?
No, he lives like that.
We need backup from a specialist.
Camera free!
I'm just an amateur when it comes to nuclear weapons.
I know.
That's why I've requested the assistance of a military analyst named Nastasha Romanenko.
Nastasha!
She'll be providing you backup by Kodak.
What?
A female analyst?
She's built up an impressive record as an advisor for the Nuclear Emergency Search Team.
After losing her parents who participated in the cleanup at Chernobyl, she moved to the US.
I've been watching a lot of stuff about Chernobyl recently.
Where is she working from?
It's like one of those morbid curiosity sort of things.
California.
Seems like a million miles away.
Snake taking a bath.
FBI, open up!
Why?
About Chernobyl?
I don't know.
Just like I said, morbid curiosity.
Those things are sort of fascinating, right?
I don't know.
The HBO show is really good.
I think I watched like a little bit of it.
Minto, I know.
Little about MGS lore.
Never finished watching but I can assume that AI summary of the chat is an accurate source of the lore.
Honestly, I can never see what the AI is saying.
So I have no idea.
Oh my gosh, I can't wait for the AI summary and MGS2.
I'm just saying.
Thank you so much for the 50 gift.
Thank you.
But yeah, the AI summaries don't show up for me.
But they're always so funny.
I love it so much.
Roy Canberra.
Says you're zooming in on snakes' toes.
Colonel, you're retired.
Why are you involved in this?
Because there aren't many people who know Foxhound as well as I do.
Is that really the only reason?
I've been soldiering for a long time.
I don't know anything else.
Even though I'm getting a little old, I still love to be in the field.
Colonel sounds so like...
Tell me the real reason.
Sometimes he sounds normal and then sometimes he sounds so like...
I'll be Frank.
Frank?
A person very dear to me is being held hostage.
Who is it?
My niece, Meryl.
Meryl.
You know I almost named my cat Meryl.
I was deciding between Meryl and pies.
Señor.
Thank you for the 10.
Gracias.
Meryl.
What was your niece doing here?
Several soldiers were reported missing the day of the revolt.
And my niece was one of those called in as an emergency replacement.
Oh my gosh, she read you.
Go have fun.
She looks like you.
She's my little brother's girl.
He died in the Gulf War.
Since then I've been watching after her.
No real combat experience.
The psychotherapy!
I'm retired.
I'm just an old man now.
And I'm your friend.
Since when are we friends?
I've thought of us as friends since the fall of Zanzibar.
With my personality, I don't have too many friends.
That's what I trust about you.
It's what makes you human.
Please, Snake.
Save my niece, Meryl.
Dramatic zoom in.
Who's the cameraman here?
How's your cat doing?
No more secrets between us.
I want complete disclosure at all times.
And two, I'll only accept orders directly from you, Colonel.
No cut-offs involved, okay?
Yeah, I only trust you, Colonel.
Agreed.
That's why I was called.
But one thing.
What?
I'm not a Colonel anymore.
Just a retired old warhorse.
I understand.
Colonel.
What?
It's so sweet.
It's so cute.
It's a good line.
It really is.
All right.
Dr. Naomi.
That doctor, is she part of this Operation 2?
She was in charge of Foxhound's gene therapy.
She knows more about those men than anyone else.
You mean you've seen them naked?
Make no mistake.
I'm not a nurse.
I'm a scientist.
Why is that the first thing you think though?
So you've seen them naked?
It's a combination of nanomachines and anti-freezing peptides so that your blood and other bodily fluids don't freeze even at sub-octic temperatures.
Nanomachines?
Not just one kind, either.
There are different types which will replenish the supply of adrenaline, nutrition, and sugar in your bloodstream.
Now I don't have to worry about food.
I wish I could get nanomachines for streaming.
Say what?
A class of drugs which will help improve your mental functioning.
Gosh, I really need these.
I need these for stream.
Benzedrine.
It's a type of stimulant.
It'll keep you alert and responsive for 12 straight hours.
Yippee!
I need these for stream!
Anything else in there?
Those nanomachines will also keep your codex batteries charged up.
Top of chat?
I guess I can call you when I'm ready to go on a diet.
You're welcome.
Click it again and refresh chat.
We'll refresh the chat.
But I don't know if it works on the backend, is what I mean.
Yeah, it doesn't work in the backend.
Since I look at chat from, like, outside of the front spacing.
But thanks for trying.
Okay.
File 3!
Oh boy!
We got all the stuff about the terrorists!
Their demands...
The people...
The chief of DARPA and the president of an arms manufacturing company.
What business did they have at a nuclear weapons disposal facility?
Oh, this one's about the hostages.
Oh my god, I remember that kanji now!
The secret exercises were being conducted at the time the terrorist group attacked.
Must be extremely important exercises if those two were directly involved.
Were they testing some kind of new advanced weapon?
I'm not privy to that information.
Do we know exactly where they're being held?
I need to find this.
Oh, Goh is not Jozu.
As you get closer, you should be able to pick up his location on your radar.
Oh yeah.
On our...
On our little radar.
Why do you know that?
It's so funny because when I studied in Japan recently, that was like one of the kanji that they... that was one of the words that we learned.
Like...
I was like, wow.
Cool.
Hostage!
You would think that I would already know that because of like...
Detective Conan or something.
Why have nanomachines when you can have gamersubs?
That was a 10% discount if you put in the code BOOMER!
Thank you.
Oh my gosh.
Shameless plug got though.
Do they really have the ability to launch a nuclear missile?
They say they do.
They even gave us the serial number of the warhead they plan to use.
Was the number confirmed?
I'm afraid so.
At the very least, they've got their hands on a real nuclear warhead.
Isn't there some kind of safety device to prevent this type of terrorism?
Camera change.
Yes.
Every missile and warhead in our arsenal is equipped with a PAL which uses a discrete detonation code.
PAL.
Permissive action link.
The safety control system built into all nuclear weapon systems.
But even so, we can't rest easy.
Why not?
Because the DARPA chief knows the detonation code.
But even if they have a nuclear warhead, it must have been removed from its missile.
All the missiles on these disposal sites are supposed to be dismantled.
I can't imagine Snake always dying his hair.
That used to be true.
But since the end of the Cold War, you can get anything if you have enough money and the right connections.
It looks blonde, but it can't be.
I think it's just the lighting and the safety.
Oh my gosh, wait.
I just noticed in the background.
You have Kenneth.
You have the diaper chief.
You have Big Boss down here.
Right next to right there.
But what is that next to him?
Who is that?
And then you have Foxhound and you have Liquid right there on the right.
Who is that next to Big Boss?
Hello, Boss.
Why are you transparent now?
Transparent?
I am a ghost.
Maybe I'm running out of energy.
Like how Mint repeats back some of the lines as a half question.
Is it the genome soldiers next to him?
No, I don't...
I can't tell.
He doesn't dye his hair.
It's just always full of mud.
Ew!
No, Foxhound is right here.
On the right.
But I mean to the left of the Big Boss portrait.
I can't tell.
There's like two little people standing.
I can't tell what that is though.
Hmm.
Oh well.
It's just Foxhound members.
It's not anyone specific.
How well armed are these terrorists?
I know there was an exercise going on at the time they revolted.
They're heavily armed I'm afraid.
And they're heavily stupid.
The six members of Foxhound in charge are all hardened veterans.
They're tough enough to eat nails than ask for seconds.
I wouldn't expect anything less from Foxhound.
The others are next generation special forces.
They're not your average grunts either.
Oh my god.
They're special guys?
They have a really... Wait, don't tell me.
If he tells me that they have a really high IQ, I think...
we're in trouble.
I think we're in trouble if he tells us that they have a really high IQ.
So what exactly are they demanding?
A person's remains.
What?
Remains?
That's right.
To be more accurate, cell specimens which contain the individual's genomic information.
Cell specimens?
Why would they want that?
The terrorists need them.
You see these next generation special forces have been strengthened through gene therapy.
Strengthened?
You've heard of the human genome project.
Oh my god.
They've been mapping the human genome and they're nearly finished.
They're gonna create a whole person.
Following up on this research, the military has been working towards identifying those genes which are responsible for making effective soldiers.
There are genes that do that?
Yes.
And using gene therapy, they're able to transplant those genes into regular soldiers.
Gene therapy?
I'll explain this part.
With gene therapy we can remove those genes which we know may lead to sickness or disease.
And at the same time splice in genes with beneficial effects such as resistance to cancer for example.
In other words, we can overcome all sorts of genetic diseases and at the same time add genetic characteristics as desired.
Okay.
And so if you knew what genes were responsible for making the perfect soldier, you could implant them in the same way, right?
No, I love Naomi.
Yes, we could.
But it all depends on being able to isolate and identify those soldier genes.
And in order to do that, it's helpful if you can study the genomic information of one of the greatest soldiers ever.
Ever!
I'm so glad we get British Naomi back.
For people who don't know, in the Twin Snakes, which is kind of like a remake of this game, they took away her accent.
Levi or Wrangler?
Like jeans?
Oh!
It took me saying jeans?
Also, ViviCore, why did you change your profile picture?
Casual Naomi hater.
I can't recognize when you guys change your profile pictures, okay?
Jeans.
What kind?
Levi?
Tommy?
Oh, we got the Tommy jeans in here too.
Oh my gosh.
I got like the cutest...
Before I couldn't go outside in Japan, I got the cutest jeans set in Japan.
I'm so happy.
I like love wearing it out.
But I feel like...
I feel like a little too flashy when I wear it.
I don't know.
Jeans are like so popular.
They're the hit thing.
The in thing now.
I used to never own a pair of jeans.
Now I own jeans.
Oh my god.
The man they call the greatest warrior of the 20th century.
You don't mean Big Boss?
That's right.
We've been working feverishly to identify the jeans responsible for his incredible combat skill.
So far we've discovered about 60 of the so-called soldier jeans.
So his body was recovered after all.
Yes.
We set that guy on fire.
His cells have remained frozen in a cryo chamber.
Just like Disney.
His genomic information is a priceless treasure to mankind.
Priceless to the military perhaps.
His body was burned severely but it was possible to restore his DNA profile from just a single strand of his hair.
Do you think Big Boss's head would be in like one of those um...
Those little head containers like in Futurama?
The strongest soldiers don't become what they are by acquiring their skills through training or experience.
We now know that hereditary factors are far more crucial for creating superior soldiers.
Snake.
We can't give them his body.
It's potentially more dangerous than all the nuclear warheads on that island put together.
I'm gonna get his body back.
The sons of Big Boss.
Oh my god.
I just made a reference that nobody here will know at all.
Okay so a lo- Okay so a long time ago I found this movie that was like a knock off of the Beverly Hills Chihuahua which I've never seen that movie before.
But the only reason I bought this movie was because the Chihuahua PNG that they used was the same on the front as the- like it was the same on the back as it was on the front just flipped.
For some reason that was so funny to me.
And in the trailer of the movie the girl- the lady is just like as a Chihuahua she's like I'm gonna get my body back.
And then she says it again but she's like I'm gonna get my body back.
So I would I would quote it a lot.
And when they were like they have to retrieve the body I'm like I'm gonna get my body back.
I'm gonna- I'm so sorry I made a reference that like literally only me and my like me and like a handful of friends would quote.
I'm so sorry.
Thanks for the mint-splaining big boss.
Name of the movie please?
I can't remember it.
There was some Chihuahua movie though.
Not Fuwawa.
Chihuahua.
Obscure mint reference.
Oh my gosh thank you for sharing your meme.
Yes it is my meme.
It wasn't Beverly Hills Chihuahua.
It was one of- you know how like movies will make like a like a like a knock off version of like you know they'll make like a knock off animated version of Finding Nemo but it's not Finding Nemo.
You know things like that.
It was just a...
Oh my gosh.
If I find it.
Beverly Hills Fuwawa.
Chihuahua the movie.
I think that's what it was.
Yes.
And the dog is so ugly.
That they use on the cover.
She's like I'm gonna get my body back.
I'm gonna get my body back.
It's Chihuahua the movie.
That's what it's called.
Show us the PNG.
Oh I can show you guys.
You're right.
Chihuahua the movie.
Okay.
Hold on.
Sorry everybody.
It has 3.9 out of 10 stars on IMDB.
So this dog is- I'm sorry to this little- This Chihuahua has done nothing.
Oh my bad.
This Chihuahua has done nothing.
But I think he just looks AI generated to me for some reason.
But this is an older movie.
It's not AI generated at all.
It's back when Chihuahua movies were so popular so they made it.
Okay so here's the cover.
And then here's the- Oh it's so tiny.
Here's the back.
It's the same dog.
Just flipped.
But he just looks a little uncanny right?
There's just something about him that just doesn't look right.
I don't know what it is.
But yeah.
Hold on.
Give me one second.
Okay.
Ugh.
Anyway.
Okay.
Next thing.
This dog's laying in eunuchs rigs.
I found the refugee.
Haha.
Did I remember it correctly or did I just gaslight myself?
It's a thinking she says it.
Until they were added that is.
They?
Who's they?
These guys didn't start out as regular army.
Looks like a pretty international group.
Mercenaries?
Yeah.
And it gets worse.
Most of them were from a merc agency that I think you're familiar with.
Oh?
They were part of Big Boss' private guard.
Running Man!
The military just bought out all their contracts.
Running Man's back!
After that they were merged with our own VR unit Force 21 and retrained.
If you ask me these so-called next generation special forces should be called simulated soldiers.
Oh.
They have no real battle experience.
Video game players, huh?
Uh oh.
Don't forget they've all been strengthened with gene therapy.
They carry genes which make them excellent soldiers.
They don't have a high IQ, right?
Don't get careless just because they don't have much experience.
Yeah.
I thought using genetically modified soldiers was prohibited by international law.
You would think.
Yes, but those are just declarations, not actual treaties.
Ooh.
The interesting thing is that nearly every member of the unit conspired in this attack.
I will not make genetically modified soldiers.
OK.
Will you sign this treaty about it?
No.
I promise.
That seems like a Maddie comic.
Where it's just like you see the president.
What's the president in this game?
I can't remember.
Oh my gosh.
No.
Of course I know what the president is in this game.
I'm so silly.
Will you see George Sears?
No.
And he's at a little convention.
And they're just like, Will you make genetically modified soldiers?
And he's like, no.
But his fingers are crossed behind his back.
And he's just like...
I imagine the face...
What's the face?
What's that comic where the guy is standing outside the window?
And he's like...
Disgusting.
I can see this in Maddie's style so clearly.
I know, right?
Yeah, the sickos.
The sickos.
I imagine like that kind of face he makes when he's just like...
I've got my fingers crossed.
Something, something, something.
No to you.
Zen means something, something, something.
How could an entire unit be subverted to rebellion?
They're calling it a revolution.
Since they all went through the same gene therapy, they probably felt closer than brothers.
They see the unit as their only family.
The sons of big boss.
Genetically engineered idol girls.
But if they were regular army, they must have been interviewed periodically by army counselors.
According to their files, they all got straight A's on their psychological tests.
They all seemed like fine, upstanding, patriotic soldiers.
But they all took part in the uprising?
No.
Several people didn't show up on the day of the exercise.
That's why there was a resupply of troops.
Was there any sign recently that something might be wrong?
There was a report a month ago that they were acting strangely.
Apparently they consulted classified information about the soldier genes and performed their own gene therapy experiments.
They can do that even without you?
Well, our gene therapy process is almost complete.
You're not needed here, Naomi.
Get out.
180?
Even the existence of this genome army is a national secret of the highest order.
I think we're in trouble.
We need to investigate this thing quietly and deal with it behind closed doors.
180 IQ!
Alright, Foxhound.
And I think we have just a few more after this.
Sorry, I know these take so long, but there's...
High tech special forces unit, Foxhound.
Foxhound!
Your former unit.
And one that I was a commander of.
What's your IQ, man?
I have no idea.
I don't think ghosts have an IQ.
They're every bit as good as when I was commanding them.
So they're still around.
There are six members of Foxhound involved in this terrorist activity.
Psycho Mantis.
With his powerful psychic abilities.
Sniper Wolf.
A beautiful and deadly sharpshooter.
She is beautiful.
Decoy Octopus.
Master of disguise.
Vulcan Raven.
Giant and Shaman.
And Revolver Ocelot.
Yes!
Specialist in interrogation.
And a formidable gun fighter.
Looks like a lovely bunch of folks.
That's the team!
Giant and Shaman.
Liquid Snake.
Liquid Snake?
Yes.
And you're the only person who can stand against him.
Because I'm Solid Snake.
Liquid Snake.
Liquid Snake!
Snake got nothing but questions.
Liquid Snake.
We should all say Liquid Snake.
Look at that smug mug.
Fresh!
USA.
When the USA moved to England upon birth.
You were there too, I believe.
He's part of the Special Force?
Sacks!
Because that guy sacks indeed.
The details are classified, but it seems that originally he penetrated the Middle East as a sleeper for the SIS.
Seven languages!
He was a spy for the British Secret Intelligence Service.
But he never once showed his face in Century House.
He was taken prisoner in Iraq.
And after that, there was no trace of him.
Ooooooh.
A little bit.
I wonder what his name could be.
Don't say it guys, don't say it.
The White Mamba.
I have a twin?
I don't know the details.
But it seems so.
That's why we really need you for this mission.
I have a twin?
You're the only one who can beat him.
Now that I've met you, I know.
You've got something that he doesn't.
I can see it in your eyes.
Why don't I find that thought more comforting?
What do I have?
She speaks in riddles.
A nice butt, yeah.
What do I have, Naomi?
What do I have?
He's got them crazy eyes.
He's so talented.
He can give himself a haircut and everything.
I only cut my bangs.
That's why they're a little crooked.
But they always end up crooked.
I just can't get it right.
I'm gonna wait it out so we can see the opening.
Wait, the opening scene is the same...
Is it the same?
I can't remember actually.
Okay, we'll just do the game then.
And yes, I will be playing on normal difficulty.
Radar off.
Nihongo.
Why does it say Nihongo?
I can't read the...
It's also so hard to read kanji, I think.
I would never recommend someone to learn kanji from an old video game.
Because it's just all blurry.
It looks like I'm looking at kanji when I need glasses.
It's so crunchy.
Not crunchy.
It's the opposite of crunchy.
But yeah, we're gonna just be playing on normal.
So...
I can't...
Something...
Nihongo not Jojo, okay?
MP5?
No!
We're not gonna play on so easy though!
Come on!
David Hayter!
If he didn't cut his hair, he would have easily fooled everyone that he was Liquid Snake and reversed everything.
The Terrorist died.
I know, right?
But...
Some flies!
But
I do know some of the names.
I do recognize some of them sometimes.
Like, Doug Stone is the voice of, uh...
Psycho Mantis.
Thanks for the super chat, you guys!
Thank you!
Okay!
If you need to, contact me by codec.
The frequency is 140.85.
When you want to use the codec, push the select button.
When we need to contact you, the codec will beep.
When you hear that noise, press the select button.
The codec's receiver directly stimulates the small bones of your ear.
It tickles!
No one but you will be able to hear it.
Got it.
Okay.
I'm ready to go.
Hold on, I'll have to remember which one to press.
Okay, so it's this one.
And then this one is the pause.
Okay, good.
Okay.
Punch!
Punch, punch!
Punch, punch, punch!
I mean, punch, punch!
Grab, grab!
Grab, grab, grab!
Punch, punch!
Punch, punch, punch!
First person!
I'm going to...
What's that sound anyway?
No one will see me.
Not even the rats.
Where's the guy?
Where is everybody?
Hello?
Oh, there they are.
I'm like, hello?
Oh.
They're coming.
They're converging.
Like, he can't see me from here, right?
I can't remember.
No.
I think we're safe.
Okay.
And does he turn around here?
I can't remember.
Don't turn around.
Oh.
Don't see me!
Okay.
We're good.
Enjoy all the killing!
I...
I enjoy it!
Yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum!
Delicious killing!
Murder, murder, mur...
I don't want him to hear me.
Which way does he go?
Go up, right?
I want the other ration over here.
We're just going to collect all these rations real quick.
Oh.
Just kidding.
There we go.
I enjoy all the killing!
Murder me thanks for the 50 gift...
Oh.
A little... 50 gifted things.
Yeah.
Maybe I'll kill this guy too.
Oh shit!
Oh.
Oh!
So
much for my no alerts run.
Which I never was going to do anyway, so it's fine!
Return your possessions, everybody.
There's nothing wrong here.
There's...
nothing wrong here.
Please.
Time to restart.
No.
God.
Please.
Where does a guy go from?
I can't...
Oh.
There he is.
We'll just go from the other side then.
Oh.
It's so good hearing the original soundtrack.
It's so good.
Yeah.
That's right.
Go away.
Oh.
Just...
What was that?
Nothing.
No one.
Actually good.
We'll distract him a little bit and then we'll...
Oh.
Come on!
Go away!
Go away.
Go away mister.
Please.
Hold on.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh.
Come on.
You bitch!
Hold on.
Let me...
How do I knock again?
Which way does he come?
Okay.
This way.
Yippee!
Showing off that 180 IQ.
Huh?
What was that noise?
Oh my gosh.
Yoshi Shikawa!
Here he comes.
I love this...
sequence.
It's him!
That's my guy!
And the controller like vibrates in that part.
It's so awesome.
Yeah!
Oh my gosh.
So cool.
Shadow Moses!
It's me doll!
So crunchy.
It's Snake.
I'm in front of the disposal facility.
Excellent Snake.
Snake, age hasn't slowed you down one bit.
How's that sneaking suit working out?
That's great.
I'm nice and dry, but it's a little hard to move.
Bear with it.
It's designed to prevent hypothermia.
This is Alaska, you know.
Take it easy.
I'm grateful.
I think snakes belong in Alaska.
If it weren't for your suit and your shot, I would have turned into a popsicle out there.
An anti-freezing peptide snake.
Ooh.
Oh my gosh.
I shouldn't have had coffee.
I'm starting to shake a lot.
I'm relieved to hear that.
Already tested, huh?
Um, no.
By the way, how's the diversionary operation going?
Two F-16s just took off from Galena and are headed your way.
Should be getting my eyes fixed soon though.
That's so awesome for you!
Though, I will miss the eyepatch even though I've never seen your face before.
What's a Russian gunship doing here?
I have no idea.
Oh my god, Snake!
I can't believe we had the same thought!
That's so crazy!
Twinsies!
It's so funny because I was in VR chat like, I think, not yesterday, the day before yesterday, and there's a recreation of this area too.
Because I was testing out some stuff and there's a recreation of this area and I was like, weeeeee!
I think...
I'll wait until it works.
Done with the codex.
You must be crazy to fly behind in this kind of weather.
Oh my god.
What a cute voice.
I haven't introduced you two yet.
This is Mei Ling.
She was assigned to us as our visual and data processing specialist.
That's good!
She designed your codec as well as your soliton radar system.
Contact her if you have any questions about either of them.
Nice to meet you, Snake.
It's an honor to speak to a living legend like yourself.
Silence.
What's wrong?
Nothing.
I just didn't expect a world class designer of military technology to be so cute.
You're just flattering me.
No, I'm serious.
Here comes one of my favorite lines.
I know I won't be bored for the next 18 hours.
Come on.
I can't believe I'm being hit on by the famous Solid Snake.
This one!
You're very frank for a trained killer.
Frank!
Looks like we both have a lot to learn about each other.
He's so smooth.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, he's so smooth.
W Riz.
The bright dot in the middle is you, Snake.
Me!
The red dots are your enemies.
And the blue corn shirt represents their field of vision.
They can't see me.
Be careful, Snake.
The genome soldiers have highly developed senses of hearing and vision due to their gene therapy.
Frank's the colonel, though.
I'll be frank.
Be sure you don't let them see you.
First, I want you to infiltrate the disposal site and look for the DARPA chief.
Okay.
The DARPA chief was injected with the same GPS-transmitting nanomachines as you.
He should appear on your radar as a green dot.
Get whatever information you can from him about the terrorists.
If he's alive, that is.
Nah, he's fine.
I believe, I believe, I believe.
Snake, your radar isn't affected by the weather.
But if you're discovered by an enemy, you won't be able to use it.
I think that's a flawed design.
Yes, it gets jammed easily, I'm afraid.
Yes, it's all made from currently existing technology.
You won't be able to use it in an area with strong harmonic resonance.
So be careful.
We'll be monitoring your movements by radar.
So contact us by codec anytime you want.
Got it.
I'll call if I'm feeling lonely.
Technology in Phantophane is so advanced.
We're here to back you up, so call if you need some information or advice.
Okay.
I'm also in charge of your mission data.
Contact me if you want me to record your current status.
My frequency is 140.96.
Okay.
It's a dedicated frequency for saving data.
Don't forget it.
Oh, I won't forget it, but...
Remember, except for your binoculars, you're naked.
I'm naked!
You need to arm yourself with whatever weapons you can find.
Okay.
I remember.
First I'm strip searched by Dr. Naomi here, and then all my weapons are taken away.
Imagine yourself put in that position.
Well, if you make it back in one piece, maybe I'll let you do it.
And then you can strip search on me.
I'll hold you to that, doctor.
By the way, sorry to disappoint you, but I did manage to smuggle out my smokes.
Oh my god, this is my favorite part.
How did you do that?
In my stomach.
Thanks to the shot you gave me that suppressed my stomach acids.
Cigarettes?
How are those going to help you?
You never know.
This guy just ate his cigarettes.
This guy is insane.
If you want to get in.
Yeah?
Let's go.
There is the front door.
It's the fastest way.
But there's too much risk of being spotted by the enemy.
We're just going to open it up.
I can't just knock on the door and ask them to let me in.
Why not?
There's one sentry on the left, no one on the right.
Why don't we steal their uniforms?
They're armed with five five sixers and pineapples.
I love pineapple.
One, two.
One, two, three.
No.
What about the air duct near the door?
That's my favorite way to get in.
There should also be a duct on the second floor.
Yes.
But that requires like going up stairs and...
I can't see it from here.
Look at him go.
He's got that nerd walk.
I'll let you decide the best COA.
Pushes out cigarettes like a pez candy dispenser.
I'm counting on you snake.
Okay.
I'm going to get in.
Alrighty.
We're in the game.
So yeah, like as you can see.
Everything.
The descriptions are in Japanese.
But like I said.
We know what things do.
So I think we'll be okay for the most part.
And uh.
Yeah.
So let's see.
There's a guy that like walks around down here.
How do I zoom in?
Oh.
Wait.
Why isn't it...
Oh okay.
There we go.
This is the quick equip and unequip.
I remember now.
Why are they JP?
Because this is integral.
Which was only released in Japan.
But.
Um.
Where is this guy?
But um.
For some reason they kept all the dub voices.
So.
It works.
Don't look this way.
That looks like a trap.
Actually.
That's a trap.
I know it's possible.
To get it.
But it still scares me.
I think I can kill this guy.
Come on.
I'm sleepy.
Turn around you son of a bitch.
Oh my god.
Not yet.
Gosh.
Don't scream like that.
You scare me.
We're okay.
What was the super chat?
Turn around.
Normie take on how the sigs were smuggled in and out.
Put them in a ziplock bag.
Swallow them.
Punch his own stomach.
Or run stomach into some blunt corner of a hard surface to puke them back up.
How do you know he puked them?
That's all I'm gonna say.
Return to your positions.
Dummies.
Wait.
It didn't summon a new guy, right?
He's still gone?
There's also the security camera though.
That we have to be careful of.
Did I get hit?
My life!
Well, might as well use it.
Wait, how do I use it?
B.
I pressed B.
Maybe here?
Oh, there we go.
Nice.
Maybe looking through here is easier then.
Let's go get our...
Let's go get the weapon.
I like how we're just chilling up here.
Oh my god.
Run, run, run, run, run.
Don't be seen.
Hello?
Oh, he's coming?
He doesn't see me.
Sometimes their vision is like so good.
And sometimes so bad.
I don't understand.
He turns to the left, right?
Yup.
Yay!
The Shokan!
So far you're two for two on being seen.
Hi, hi, hi!
Also, isn't he supposed to be asleep in front of that camera?
What are you doing walking around?
You busy guy?
You're so busy or something?
Oh my goodness.
Aren't you supposed to be asleep?
Over there!
Am I crazy?
Go to bed!
Different guy.
I wonder if I can grab him.
He's gonna turn around though, right?
He's gonna turn this way?
No he doesn't.
Interesting.
But then he turns around.
When does he turn around?
I wanna get the little cutscene where he goes to surveillance camera.
You know?
Oh my god.
So close.
Wee!
Not playing on the mint mod?
It's not quite ready yet.
Oh yeah, I meant to say that before.
I was told it's not quite ready yet.
But once it is, we will play on it.
No worries.
It's over here, right?
Surveillance camera.
Oh my god.
I don't wanna get caught though.
Surveillance camera?
Why would they need that?
What are they trying to be sneaky or something?
Oh my god.
Go away.
Turn around.
Yeah, that's right.
Oh my god.
Why can't you be asleep?
I'm not gonna get caught, am I?
We're fine.
Does this way have anything?
How are you supposed to not get caught there?
I truly do wonder.
Yeah, we'll follow the rats.
I wanted to get this first though.
Oh, that's right.
We're full.
Okay, never mind.
We're gonna go full.
With a chaff grenade?
But I don't have that.
Like, I know you can't shoot out the cameras in this game, right?
For a ghost, you're bad at being invisible?
What?
It's because I'm so comfortable.
I'm so used to being invisible as a ghost.
I'm not so used to being invisible as a human.
You know what I mean?
Master Miller!
What are you doing here?
I quit being a drill instructor.
So I moved out here for some peace and quiet.
I'm in retirement just like you.
Once in a while, I still help train the Alaskan scouts.
Passing on the skills to a new generation, huh?
I love Master Miller!
Campbell told me about the situation here.
This guy makes a mean hamburger.
I thought I might be of some use.
There's no one I'd rather have in a foxhole than you.
Well, I know lots about survival in a harsh environment.
I've lived in Alaska longer than you.
So call me if you have any questions about the Alaskans.
I'm gonna call you all the time.
My frequency is 141.80.
I should probably like...
Okay, hold on.
Those mice are Alaskan field mice.
Don't worry.
They can't hurt you.
Wild field mice don't have a thick layer of fat.
But they can still survive the bitter winters here without hibernating.
That's crazy.
They dig tunnels under the snow.
That's where they stay warm.
Survival specialists, huh?
How do they taste?
I should learn from them.
But there's a dark side too.
They eat the soil and eat offspring that's not their own.
To ensure the survival of their own genes, right?
Yeah.
Pretty brilliant program, huh?
If there are mice, that means there must be an exit somewhere.
Follow the mice.
Befriend the mice.
Okay.
There we go.
Sorry.
The Soliton radar won't work in a narrow space.
That's okay.
Too much harmonic resonance.
The radio waves produce interference.
And we can't analyze the topographic data.
You're doing amazing, Mary.
Try to hang on until you get to a more open space, okay?
Okay.
Love you.
Yay.
Don't give up, Snake.
Sorry.
The Soliton radar...
Oh, she's just gonna keep saying this.
We'll do the save thing once we're out of the hole.
Those mice are Alaskan field mice.
Don't worry.
They can't hurt you.
I just needed reassurance, okay?
I just needed the reassurance.
We're fine.
We're still...
This feels like Tokyo Jungle.
Why does the vent have so much water in it?
This place is...
I honestly couldn't tell you.
He's right here.
Stop being so shocked by me.
I'm trying to befriend you.
I have snacks.
Don't you want a ration?
They're like, don't feed us that nastiness.
Look at them go.
We'll wait for him to circle around again.
We gotta go find a diaper chief.
Gross ration.
Is ration basically like an MRE?
There he is.
Yeah?
Okay.
Thanks for the super chat.
Hold on one second.
I'm gonna do this real quick.
I'm gonna actually pin a message that says, Please no spoilers in chat Not for me but for anyone who's new to the series.
We want to have this be safe place for all watchers.
Thank you!
There we go.
And I'll just pin that.
Instead.
Snake dies... with me playing it?
Probably.
If I'm the one in control?
Most likely.
MRE is a specific type of ration.
Here he comes.
I forgot there's two of them here.
And then he stops.
When he stops there, does he look this way?
I can't remember.
Or bring back the smiley?
Oh yeah!
Meals ready to eat.
Oh!
I wish I could see him.
There he is.
Okay.
Oh my gosh, that was close, I think.
Oh my god.
The tank area music is just so good.
Dun dun.
Oh, hello?
Thanks,
Colonel!
There's a maid that kills... a snake... a few times.
Uh, wait, what's the button?
Oh, there we go.
Ooh!
I think I see him.
That little squiggly.
Oh my gosh.
He's really freaking out in there.
He's like...
It's Missingno!
The DARPA chief has turned into Missingno!
Look at the radar.
It's picking up the DARPA chief.
He's the green dot.
Hurry and rescue him!
Oh my god!
We gotta hurry!
We gotta get that guy.
Boop boop.
Dun dun.
Nothing here.
I hate how much this game has literally changed my... it has rewired my brain.
Press the action button.
Like, I can't say nothing here normally anymore.
I have to go...
Nothing here.
Just because of Metal Gear Solid 2.
It's so insane.
I just can't.
I can't live normally anymore, you guys.
It's a problem.
Wait, do I... do I need the rations?
I'm so used to hoarding rations because I always need them.
But I think we're fine for now.
I thought the action button was always triangle.
Am I crazy?
That's why I was like... wait.
Because that's how I got into the car, right?
I don't know.
You're crazy.
No, it's... I'm pressing circle.
I thought it was triangle.
Japanese... oh, the Japanese one is different.
That's why.
Wait, how do I look down?
Is it action?
Circle?
Square?
X?
I should just have that equipped, shouldn't I?
Triangle?
No.
Circle?
Tilt your head down.
Just use your neck, dummy.
Triangle plus down?
Or triangle plus down?
Ah, thank you!
I hate Alaska.
Boy, oh boy, that woman is built around here.
That woman is... holy... that shit kind of sucks in.
God, I was thinking about women on the toilet.
That's my favorite activity.
Gosh, I'm going to think about every woman on the toilet.
Oh, here we go.
We can see around in there.
Thank you.
Hi, that guy.
What a silly guy on the toilet.
Catching colds in Alaska.
You would think that being in, like, being, you know, a super soldier, shouldn't you have a better immune system?
This guy just kind of sucks.
He's IQ 179.
Everyone else is 180.
He's just 179.
Not him.
This scary music is so funny.
A woman!
Snake, the DARPA chief signal is coming from somewhere in that area.
Isn't there someplace to drop down?
Take a look around in first person view mode.
I'm looking.
Actually...
Master!
Snake, you've got to think.
Your mind is your most dangerous weapon.
Got to think?
If things are getting too complicated, try to simplify them.
Try your thoughts.
You can also try calling Campbell for advice.
Or you, because I'm your master.
Instructor.
Okay.
He has a point.
Don't agree with him.
Oh, here we go.
Nice angle.
Who's that?
I'm here to save you.
You're the DARPA chief, Donald Anderson, right?
You're here to save me, huh?
What's your outfit?
I'm the pawn they sent here to save your worthless butt.
A Gucci Prada.
Really?
It's true.
You don't look like one of them.
George Butt!
In that case, hurry up and get me out of here.
Slow down.
Don't worry.
First, I want some information.
About the terrorists.
Yeah.
The terrorists?
What do you mean the...
Do they really have the ability to launch a nuke?
What are you talking about?
Why are you so shocked?
The terrorists are threatening the White House.
They say if they don't exceed to their demands, they'll launch a nuclear weapon.
Sweet Jesus.
Is it possible?
What?
How does this guy not know?
It's possible.
They...
Phantom Snake welcomed the membership.
Thank you.
...could launch a nuclear weapon.
What?
How did they plan to launch?
I thought this place was just for keeping the dismantled warheads.
What?
They shouldn't have access to a missile.
What I'm about to tell you is classified information.
Okay?
Okay.
I'm ready.
We're conducting exercises with a new type of experimental weapon.
A weapon that will change the world.
What?
A weapon with the ability to launch a nuclear attack from any place on the face of the Gucci snaking suit 2024.
A nuclear-equipped walking battle tank.
What?
Uh-oh.
Wait, I thought that was just a rumor.
Ah.
Metal gear.
Metal gear!
It can't be.
You knew?
God.
Oh my God.
Metal gear is one of the most secret black projects.
How did you know that?
Oh my gosh.
Rex is so cute.
We've had a couple of run-ins in the past.
So that's the reason you were here at this disposal site?
Metal gear.
Why else would I come to a god-forsaken place like this?
I had heard the metal gear project was scrapped.
Yeah.
On the day of the launch, I heard that the project was scrapped.
It's actually the contrary.
Oh my God.
It's grown into a huge joint project between Arms Tech and ourselves.
They made it even better!
We were going to use this exercise as raw data, and then proceed to mass production.
They made him crazy.
They made him roar like a dinosaur.
If it hadn't been for the revolution...
The revolution.
Rex has fallen into the hands of terrorists.
Rex?
I'm sorry.
Rex!
Metal Gear Rex!
This guy is like, uh, why are you talking?
Wave him away.
Get outta here!
Hey, shut up in there, will ya?
I'm thinking back to the Twin Snakes where he literally Spider-Manned on the ceiling.
Pal!
My little buddy, my pal, my friend.
Each of us needs to input our password or there can be no launch.
But...
But?
They found out my password.
You're so weak.
You talked.
Psycho Mantis can read people's minds.
You can't resist.
Psycho Mantis?
One of the members of Foxhound.
He has psychic powers.
Psychic powers?
This is bad.
Hahahaha.
It's just a matter of time before they get Baker's 2.
Can they marry you, little creep?
If they find out Baker's password...
Stop eavesdropping.
Yes.
They'll be able to launch a nuke any time.
Uh-oh.
But there is a way to stop the launch.
What?
The card keys.
Card keys?
They were designed by ArmsTech, the system developers, as an emergency override.
Oh, good.
Even without the passwords, you can just insert the card keys and engage the safety lock.
And if I do that?
Yes.
You can stop the launch.
I'm zooming on the toilet paper.
Hahahaha.
That card key.
So where are the keys?
Mmm.
Baker should have them.
The card keys.
You need three card keys.
Okay.
There are three different slots to put them in.
You need to insert a card into each one of them.
Okay.
Three card keys.
Got it.
Do you know where they might be keeping Baker?
We are talking so loudly.
Somewhere in the second floor bedroom.
Okay.
Second floor basement.
Second floor basement?
I heard the guards say they moved him to an area that has a lot of electronic jamming.
Ah.
Any other clues?
Yes.
They cemented over the entrances, but didn't have enough time to paint them.
Why don't you look for the areas where the walls are a different color?
Different color.
Mmm.
Here.
Take this.
It's my ID card.
Yippee!
It'll open any level one security door.
It's called a pad card.
Pad.
It works together with your bank account.
I just noticed.
Are there like bugs on the floor?
Personal area network, huh?
Are there bugies on the floor?
It transmits data using the salts in your body as the transmission medium.
As you approach the door's security devices, they'll read the data stored in the card.
And the doors will open automatically.
Gotcha.
Yippee!
Okay.
I'm gonna get you out of here.
Yeah.
Wait a minute.
I mean...
What is it?
You haven't heard any other way to disarm the pad?
Have you?
From your bosses or anyone?
No.
Are you sure you haven't heard anything?
I just said no.
So does the White House plan to give in to the terrorist demands?
That's their problem.
It has nothing to do with my orders.
But what about the Pentagon?
Pentagon?
Uh-oh.
What is it?
Oh my God.
Are you...
Oh!
The toilet's right there.
You can make it.
What's that?
Diaper chief.
Oh!
Hey, what happened?
Oh my God.
His stomach was really growling.
I think he has IBS, you guys.
I think he has IBS for real.
Oh!
It's a heart attack, but...
A heart attack?
No.
Colonel, are you hiding something from me?
Absolutely not.
Snake, you've got to understand.
This op is security level red.
You need the highest security clearance to get access to the complete file.
You want me to believe that you're in charge of this op, but you don't have complete access to the file?
Oh.
I told you.
The Secretary of Defense is in operational control.
I'm just here as your support.
Snake, we don't have time to debate.
Where's the fire wind to it?
Snake?
Oh!
He's hiding in the ceiling of the prison.
And out of there, find President Baker.
Um...
Oh!
What's going on out there?
Yeah?
Oh!
You think it's safe?
What could it be?
They're just little pixels on the ground.
Ewww!
I died here.
Besides this guy.
Um...
Oh!
Don't move!
So you can't get out of here.
I killed the Chief.
You bastard!
It wasn't me!
Liquid?
No.
You're not.
Liquid.
Don't move!
The way he looks like he's in springing action.
Is this the first time you ever pointed a gun at a person?
Oh.
Your hands are shaking.
You got them, rookie eyes.
Can you shoot me, rookie?
Careful.
I'm no rookie.
Liar.
That nervous glance.
I'm not a rookie.
That scared look in your eyes.
Rookie, rookie, rookie.
They're rookie's eyes if I ever saw them.
Screams rookie.
You've never shot a person, am I right?
You talk too much.
You haven't even taken the safety off, rookie.
I told you, I'm no rookie.
Uh-oh.
They've heard him.
You're not one of them, are you?
Ah!
I never knew how they...
Open that door.
You've got a card, don't you?
Why?
How they, like...
So we can get the hell out of here.
Come in, you know?
Looks like we'll be a little delayed.
I never understood why they show up here.
What are you doing?
Don't think.
Shoot.
That's so...
Wait.
How do I shoot?
X button.
I'm
waiting for you.
Shoot.
Don't talk to me like a rookie.
I'm telling you.
Shoot.
Yeah!
But him saying, like, don't think, shoot is so Top Gun.
So funny.
Ah!
Nice.
Good job, guys.
Oh.
I'm out of bullets.
Ah!
I just saw it as soon as I ran back over.
Shoot.
Oh, wait.
Why did I use that?
When I...
Shoot.
Always gets me, too.
Thanks for the help.
Hey.
Oh.
Wait.
That's a nice butt.
Nice push.
You fool.
You've killed him.
Killed who?
I'm sorry, sir.
His mental shielding was very strong.
I could not dive into his mind.
Now, we'll never get that detonation code.
Huh?
Boss.
So happy that you're back.
Thank you.
I love you.
Bye.
Huh?
Who did they kill?
Oh.
Ah!
She's just emptying her entire thing.
Yeah!
Oh.
Oh!
Psychomantis.
Good girl.
Just like that.
Hey.
He called Snake a good girl.
I'm going crazy.
He called YOU a good girl.
That guy's crazy.
Wait, what is the... what is the... how do I get in here?
This... his little pants.
He's a boxers type of guy.
Wait, is this boxers or is this briefs?
Here, I'll give you a better angle.
Boxers are briefs.
Those are boxers.
Briefs?
Which one?
Uh, which bed?
The bed has the... so let's unequip that.
This way.
Uh, excuse me, sir.
I'm just gonna steal the stuff under your butt.
The fight sequence was one of the instances where you have to kill to progress the game even on big boss rank, which limits your kills.
Yeah!
That's so interesting.
I did think about that, like...
Anything in here?
We're so calm.
Isn't in Twin Snakes you get the magazine in here though, right?
So nasty.
You're a nasty fella.
Mysterious man.
We don't know your name yet.
If you even have a name.
Oh, I already... wait.
I don't have full life, so...
I guess we'll come back for this ration if we ever need it.
And we can't.
Boop-boop.
Boop-boop!
Second floor basement.
Yeah.
See, I'm pressing circle.
It's so weird.
But I thought I pressed triangle to get into the truck.
Hmm.
I'm not... I'm not sure.
Second floor basement.
Second floor basement!
There's no one here yet, right?
Pretty sure.
Pretty sure we're safe.
Besides the floors.
The floors open up here, and they're quite evil.
Ah!
You killed me!
Xanflex, thank you so much for the pink!
Still remember playing this at my cousin's place.
Never had the chance to finish it.
Well, let's finish it together!
Bye bye!
It's this one here, right?
Grenades!
I don't remember any of them.
Doesn't need a name.
I'm sure we'll never see him again.
This one also.
I'm so paranoid.
I'm so paranoid if any of them has lasers.
This is level two.
Oh, the FAMAS!
Okay.
Let's try and remember these.
FAMAS is in here.
Nikita missiles... in here.
C4... in here.
And this is... Stinger?
Oh, yeah.
Yes.
PSG... no.
This is... sorry.
Sniper... here.
Okay.
And then what's... and then the...
And then we got the grenades down here.
Yes.
This is a sniper, actually.
In my brain!
I knew it was a sniper.
I promise you.
I'm not lying.
I'm not.
Where's the trap doors?
We literally walked over one.
Chatters are discussing Solid Snake's nakedness.
Or what looks like nakedness in the Metal Gear Solid game.
The Boxer Briefs theory seems to be the most popular consensus.
Wait!
There's something... What is...
What is a Boxer Briefs?
Whoa.
Wait a second.
Do I have to use the grenade?
Oh, gosh.
I thought I used C4 here.
Where... which... where's the C4 room?
It was this one.
Aha!
Let's just unequip these so I don't accidentally miss.
Oh, these look like lockers for a second.
What's it say?
No smoking!
There we go.
X button.
B button.
I wish it...
Okay.
I think... Okay.
There we go.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run.
Nice.
Okay.
They said it's in a place with jamming.
Nothing here.
Except a weirdly colored wall.
He, he, he.
Before we move on...
I, I need to use the little ghosties room.
Oh, so, um...
Let's... we haven't called Master in a minute.
Let's see what he has to say.
Soldiers that have been forged in the fires of battle are used to catching naps whenever and wherever they can.
Naps?
There's a big difference between real soldiers and those kids who have only been trained in VR simulators.
That's not... I'm a real soldier.
After playing for a long time, you should get some rest too.
Oh.
It hasn't even been that long, Master.
It hasn't even been two hours.
Um, I was gonna say...
You... please backseat me on the codex.
I ask you to because...
Um...
Because I've played before, I'll forget to call them.
So please, if you're just like...
Hey, you haven't called Campbell in a while.
Or you haven't called Master Miller.
Or you haven't called someone.
Oh, yeah, Nastasha!
Let's get her.
What is it?
One...
Four, one...
Five, two...
Wait.
Wait, how do I...
One, four, one, five, two.
Oh!
Oopsie, my bad.
This is Nastasha Romanenko.
A pleasure to work with you, Solid Snake.
Thank you.
You're the nuclear specialist that the Colonel mentioned.
That's me.
You can ask me anything about nukes that you want.
I am also a military analyst.
You haven't called Chat in a while.
So I have an extensive knowledge of weapon systems as well.
Ooh la la.
You can ask me to participate in this operation as a supervisor from the Nuclear Emergency Search Team.
I was happy to accept.
We must not allow terrorists to get their hands on nuclear weapons of any kind.
No.
I hope I can help you to stop them.
You're a tough lady.
Those terrorists are serious about launching a nuclear weapon?
Thank you!
The world cannot stand by idly and allow that to happen.
And neither can I.
I love idly.
Unfortunately, all I can do from here...
Is that a cigarette?
I think so.
Hopefully that'll be enough.
Another soldier here wouldn't make a difference anyway.
It's good to work with you, Nastasha.
Same here, Snake.
So yeah, if I forget after some time, if you're just like, hey, save or whatever.
I don't mind that kind of backfiring.
Snake, you can't use your radar in that area.
There's some kind of electronic damning coming from there.
I wonder what it is.
Anyway, be careful.
Actually, what is it?
That's weird.
It's jamming this area.
Have my babies, please, Nastasha.
First of all, her name's Nastasha, not Natasha.
I don't think she's gonna have your babies if you can't get her name right.
You can at least do...
You can at least have that common courtesy for her, you know?
Elris.
Be careful, Snake.
No, I want... I want... Where's my proverb?
Oh, whoops.
I didn't mean to call again.
Snake, you can't use your radar...
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
Thank you.
Hold on.
Let's go into the other area and get our silly little Mei Ling face.
What's up, Snake?
Talk to you later, Snake.
Bye.
What can I do for you, Snake?
Nothing.
Be careful, Snake.
Thank you.
She's so cute.
She's so sweet.
You called, Snake?
Come on, Snake.
Don't call me for no reason.
Do I need a reason to see her cute little face?
Uh-oh.
She's pouting her cheeks at...
She's pouting her cheeks at me.
She's pouting
her cheeks at me.
So close.
Next one, maybe.
Do not save.
Beep.
It's so good every time.
It's so good!
Okay, give me one second.
I'm gonna go fishing.
Gone fishes.
BRB, I'm going to the little ghost's room.
Sorry, I had too much coffee.
And tea.
I'll be right back.
I'll be fast.
I don't know where my phone is.
I don't think I brought it.
Oops.
I don't know where I put my phone.
Uh-oh.
I like to check if I have any missed messages or anything while I'm peeing.
I'm back.
Oh, I should have gotten more tea.
That's okay.
I still have a little bit.
I have a cut on my lip.
And it hurts every time I smile.
So I'm just gonna... I'm gonna frown the whole stream.
Ouch.
It's because when I had, um...
When I had...
I get really dry lips.
And when I had COVID, I didn't want to use any of my lip balms because I was like, I'll have to get rid of them afterwards because...
They'll be infected.
Stick, remember what Confucius said.
The man who runs in front of a car gets tired.
But the man who runs behind a car gets exhausted.
MGS Sneaky Music ASMR Channel.
Uh-oh.
Ah.
Wait.
Oh, okay, good, good, good.
Sorry.
I thought, uh...
I thought my controller turned off.
Why didn't you just use your finger?
Because it's not like... it's not like the fingery type.
It's like the ones that you...
It's not like the one you squeeze.
So...
My lips can't...
I can't cut them.
Yeah.
Anyway.
Let's actually save.
Oh, she's still mad at me.
I'm gonna save this time.
Mei-Ling, please believe me.
I'm gonna save.
Wait, didn't I just save?
You know what?
It's fine.
Taco Mei-Ling.
Thanks for the 10 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Thank you guys for all the donuts while I was gone too.
Snake, listen to what Lochi said.
He who knows that enough is enough will always have enough.
Just because you see an item doesn't mean that you always have to get it.
If you don't really need it, think twice before you stick your neck out.
It might not be worth it.
Don't tell me that.
That's my least favorite one, Mei-Ling.
Good.
Looks like it worked.
If what the DARPA chief said is true, President Baker should be up ahead.
Hurry up and get him out of there.
Okay.
We'll get him.
Easy peasy.
Don't tell me what to do.
Oh!
I'm still gone fishing.
My bad.
Thank you.
Let's...
Let's go.
Oh.
Huh.
I don't even think if they had painted over it, it would have...
It would have made a difference.
First of all, why are they so, like, haphazardly...
Like, why aren't they just doors?
Like, did this hallway just lead to nowhere?
Like, what's...
What's the deal, yo?
What was the point?
Why aren't they, like, square-shaped like a normal door?
I'm just so...
I'm so confused.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run!
I should go...
I'm gonna go grab some more C4, actually.
So that we have it...
So that we have it before...
Um...
We continue onwards, you know?
So I don't have to come back in here, is what I meant.
Which...
I might...
I don't have to anyway, but you know.
It's fine.
Got a C4 cheese here.
No, I think I'll do it normally.
This wasn't a particularly difficult fight, so...
I think it's okay.
And...
Some people had real trouble with this boss their first time.
I guess we'll see.
Maybe I got lucky.
I don't know.
I'm just remembering the Twin Snakes version of this fight and how ridiculously easy it was.
I want to go back to the Twin Snakes for all the boss fights.
Okay, here we go!
What could be in here?
Who's that?
Oh my god.
You got...
Ooh, there's a little sexy going on here.
You're the arms tech president, Kenneth Baker, right?
Don't worry, I'm here to save you.
No, no, don't touch it!
C4.
Don't touch it!
I'm close!
Right.
Touch that wire and the C4 will blow up along with the old man.
So you're the one that the boss keeps talking about.
And you?
Special operations, Foxhound.
Revolver Ocelot.
I've been waiting for you, Solid Snake.
Now we'll see if the man can live up to the legend.
This is the greatest handgun ever made.
Oh my god, I look really...
The cult's single action arm.
No.
Six bullets.
More than enough to kill anything that moves.
Oh my god, he said the thing.
I'm sorry.
Now I'll show you why they call me...
This is my favorite character.
Revolver.
He's so awesome.
Traaa!
I forgot to...
Ow.
Oh my god...
The lady won't help you.
Ooh.
Wait.
Wait, I'm confused.
Wait, why is my thing not equipping?
That was weird.
Okay, um, ouch!
Oh my gosh.
I'm guessing, I'm guessing.
I'm just guessing, I'm just guessing.
Ouch, ouch, ouch.
Oh my god, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
I forget the strat a little bit with this one, but...
Oh my god!
Oh.
Oh my god, I can't, I can't do the same thing he does.
Oh shoot, he's over there!
I missed my shot!
Oh, no I didn't.
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch.
Where's the rations?
There are some here, right?
Ugh.
Where are you?
Oh.
Come here.
Come here, you little bitch.
Where is he?
Ouch!
Oh my god.
Ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch, ouch.
Please.
Oh my god.
I just, I almost had him.
I almost had him.
Where, where you at?
Where is he at, actually?
Oh, there he is.
Ugh.
Infinity frames.
Where you at?
We're dancing.
Oh my gosh, you guys, we're dancing.
What you gonna do, Ocelot?
What you, what you, are you gonna shoot me?
What are you gonna do?
Come on.
Shoot me, Ocelot.
What?
Oh, that was close.
That was close.
That was really close.
Um, I know he runs here.
Ugh.
Oh, shoot.
Where you at?
Oh.
You're pretty good.
That's what I'd expect from the man with the same code as the boss.
It's been a long time since I had such a good fight.
But I'm just getting warmed up.
Ooh, look at him go.
You're so...
What?
My hand!
He sounds so not Ocelot when he says that.
Oh my god!
Kenneth!
Stealth camouflage.
Can't you even die right?
You were lucky.
We'll meet again.
Who are you?
I like you.
I have no name.
I have a name.
Just like...
That... that exoskeleton.
He killed
Kenny!
Not yet.
So funny.
Oh my god.
Who the hell?
MGS1 Ocelot had the best strip IMO.
Can you talk?
Who are you?
I'm not one of them.
The DARPA chief told me he gave them his detonation code.
What about yours?
Oh, I get it.
Jim sent you.
Jim!
Answer my question.
What about your code?
There's no time.
I... talked.
What?
Now the terrorists have both codes and can launch any time.
That was the guy who sent Jim.
It's not like I didn't fight.
Jim Pentagon.
I managed to resist Psycho Mantis' mind probe.
He couldn't read you?
How'd you do it?
Surgical implants in my brain.
Surgical implants?
Kind of like a psychic insulation.
Everyone who knows these top secret codes has it.
Even the DARPA chief?
Of course.
But the DARPA chief said Mantis got his code by reading his mind.
Yeah, how did...
Are you sure you heard him right?
Yeah, that's what he said.
Yeah, I'm sure.
In that case, how did they get your code?
I never had any training on how to resist torture.
They gave you the psychic resistance, but torture is not as important, I guess?
Oh, he's not human.
I tell you, he loved every second of it.
What happened to your arm?
He broke it.
He loves it.
This guy's a wimp.
Looks like you're more than even now.
His was sliced off.
You're a funny man.
So the DARPA chief, is he okay?
He's got jokes.
Dead.
What?
I can't be.
Get out of here.
That's not what you promised him.
Now you want to shut me up?
Calm down.
What's wrong with you?
I just told you I was here to save you.
Now kiss.
I didn't kill the DARPA chief.
He had a heart attack or something.
You think?
A heart attack?
No.
Oh, don't be a fool.
Anyway, the Terras have both codes now.
It's a very convenient time to have a heart attack.
Those boys are totally insane.
They wouldn't hesitate to launch.
I agree.
But what do they really want?
They want to kill me.
Who knows?
Maybe they're like us in the arms industry.
Always looking forward to the next good war.
Well, I'm not going to let these maniacs start a war today.
You still have the card keys.
Card keys?
To override the detonation code.
I heard you had them.
Oh.
No.
Not anymore.
What?
Who does then?
Not the Terras?
No.
That woman.
Woman?
Who?
The one with the nice butt.
The soldier that was thrown in prison along with me.
A female soldier.
It must be.
She said she was a woman.
She had just joined up as a new recruit.
Oh my gosh.
They threw her in prison because she refused to take part in the rebellion.
There's no other women here.
Could that be the Colonel's niece?
What if he meant sniper woman?
I gave her the key.
Looks like she managed to break out of here though.
I hope she's okay.
I'm sure she is.
She's green.
But as tough as they come.
But how did you know she escaped?
I was in contact with her by codec.
Oh.
Until I was tied up here that is.
Codec?
Yes.
She stole it from the guards.
If she still has it, you should be able to contact her.
Okay.
What's your frequency?
I'm sure she still has it.
What frequency was she at?
Oh yeah.
Let me tell you this.
It's...
Oh gosh.
IBS?
No?
Sorry.
I forgot.
Damn.
He forgot.
Oh that's right.
It should be on the back of the CD case.
Try to contact her.
Oh.
I'll contact her right away.
Okay.
But tell me.
If this doesn't work, is there some other way to prevent the missile launch?
Hmm.
You need to find Hal Emmerich, one of my employees.
Who's that?
The team leader of the Metal Gear Rex project.
He sounds like a...
He sounds like a nerd!
A genius in engineering.
But a little bit of an oddball.
If there's anyone who can figure out how to stop Metal Gear from launching, it's him.
What if he can't come up with anything?
You'll have to destroy it.
Emmerich knows how to destroy Metal Gear.
Where is this Emmerich?
Well, he's probably being held somewhere in the nuclear warhead storage building.
Okay.
It's north from here.
That's where he worked.
I know where that is.
I understand.
But why Metal Gear?
Why Metal Gear?
The nuclear age ended with the turn of the millennium.
Oh, you're wrong.
The threat of nuclear war isn't gone.
In fact, it's greater than it's ever been.
Uh-oh.
The amount of spent nuclear fuel and plutonium...
Real footage!
...is increasing even today.
Listen.
Have you ever seen a warehouse full of nuclear material?
No.
Drums and drums of nuclear waste.
They're stacked this high.
As far as you can see.
Because there's still no real way to dispose of the stuff.
So they just close the lid and try to pretend like it'll go away?
Essentially, yes.
Oh my god.
And they're not even doing a good job of storing it.
Many of the drums are corroded...
Oh god!
...with nuclear waste seeping out of them.
Unbelievable.
That's getting into my food!
And only that, and several pounds of muff are reported every year.
So you mean to have nuclear waste and microplastics to worry about?
It proves that there's a large and well-organized black market for nuclear waste.
And since the end of the Cold War, Russian nuclear engineers in particular are out of work with no way to turn.
In other words, there's plenty of available nuclear material and scientists for making a bomb.
What?
Never heard that before.
We live in an age when any small country can have a nuclear weapons program.
What about the other superpowers?
Russia and China still maintain a significant nuclear presence.
Complete nuclear disarmament is an impossibility.
To maintain our own policy of deterrence, we need a weapon of overwhelming power.
You mean Metal Gear.
Yes.
Not the deterrence.
You know our industry suffered quite a blow as a result of the cuts in military budgets due to this so-called peace.
I remember hearing a lot about mergers and takeovers among the big weapons makers.
Yes.
And after my company lost their bid to produce the Air Force's next line of fighter jet, the Metal Gear system was off.
This is our last ace in the hole.
That's why we pushed to have Metal Gear developed as a black project.
Black project?
Secret projects paid for by the Pentagon's black budget.
You can avoid a lot of red tape and get a great lead time on your weapons production.
And no one can bother you.
Not even those bleeding-heart liberals on the military oversight committee.
Love the turns.
Lost in the sword, they give you the tech gift.
Brimes.
I prefer to think of it as grime.
Good business.
Anyway, Metal Gear was going to be formally adopted after the results of this exercise were analyzed.
Oh my gosh.
That's not that super-jack.
The timing is...
I don't give a crap about your company.
So perfectly.
Yes.
That's about what I'd expect from a grunt like you.
Here.
This is what you came for, right?
What's that?
Thanks, Jamie.
An optical disc.
It's all here.
The main hard drive was destroyed by gunfire.
This is the only remaining copy of the data.
What kind of data?
Bribes.
All the data collected from this exercise...
Bribes!
Don't play dumb.
It's the way.
I know you were sent to get this.
I'm sorry to hear you.
I hid it from that sadistic maniac while he was torturing me.
They don't know this disc exists.
Make sure you report this to Jim.
To your boss.
I don't report to Jim.
I'll give you my card, too.
Oh, thanks.
It'll open up all security level two doors.
Can you walk?
No.
No, you go on without me.
They got my password.
They don't want anything else from me.
I have one more question.
Who or what?
What was that ninja thing?
Yeah, who was that?
It looked like you knew something.
That ninja?
Who's that ninja?
It's Foxhound's dark little secret.
Dark little secret?
An experimental genome soldier.
Ew.
Cover your mouth.
You know him?
You should ask Dr. Naomi Hunter from Foxhound.
She knows better than I.
Naomi.
Naomi Sass?
And I'm finished!
It's time to play more Metal Gear.
Metal Gear?
Yes!
What?
Doesn't Metal Gear use currently existing technology?
Thanks for...
Metal Gear itself does, but...
Oh!
I heard his tummy.
He was gurgling!
What did you do to me?
Oh, no.
No!
Jim!
Oh!
Oh no!
It can't be!
Those pentagon bastards!
So...
They actually went and...
What are you talking about?
They are just using you for...
His tummy hurt.
IBS, IBS, IBS, IBS.
Kenny!
Those bastards!
They killed Kenny!
Are you listening?
Now he's dead too.
I have no idea.
Don't lie to me.
It looked like another heart attack, but some kind of poison.
What do you know, Miss Naomi?
There are lots of drugs that can cause a heart attack in large doses.
For example, potassium chloride or dioxides, but we won't be able to tell without doing an autopsy.
Snake, I want you and Meryl to work together.
Can I trust her?
More than you can trust me.
Get in contact with her.
Snake, there's a lot of electrical interference.
It should be okay if you do burst transmission like us, but normal transmission is probably impossible.
Try moving away from that area.
I love that line so much.
Snake, get a hold of yourself.
Naomi, what the hell was that ninja thing?
Yeah, you have some explaining to do.
Remember Foxhound?
No.
Are you sure?
Yes, we have no one like that in our unit.
Is that right?
She had a look on her face.
Snake, I'm counting on you.
She looked concerned for a moment.
Oh, thank goodness.
Oh, I got an achievement.
Versus Revolver Ocelot.
Defeat Revolver Ocelot.
Nice.
Aww, he's dead.
IBS.
Was there blood on him?
Is that like... see that red there?
Hmm.
Is there any other ration in here or...
No
other ration.
Oh.
Beep, beep.
Four.
I don't think I've ever gone through this door before.
I don't remember ever going through this door.
It's so funny.
And then here, there's... that.
You can't see me now, though, right?
I can probably get that ration.
Raaaaa...
Nice.
I think there's other security cameras down the way, right?
I can't go in through here, though, right?
No.
Or, like, rather, there's no reason for me to go down there right now, because I don't think I can go through any of the doors.
I've not even noticed that.
Nice one.
Oh, not once?
I thought you said, nice one.
I just complimented myself.
I just completely complimented myself by misreading your own comment.
Thanks.
Nice one, Mint.
Thanks, Mint.
Thanks.
We go into the void.
But now...
Now we go back in here.
I forgot to mention this yesterday, but I got the postcard.
I don't...
Wait, hold on.
Oh, shoot.
Can I go in here?
Oh, uh, I wouldn't know.
I can!
Okay.
I don't remember what places have the...
We're just gonna be safe on all accounts.
Grenade.
Oh, wait.
This is the grenade room.
Hahaha.
What's this?
It's safe.
I forgot to mention this yesterday, but I got the postcard.
I don't care that it has a tire mark on it.
It gives character.
Well, we care.
But I'm...
Thank you.
Thanks for signing up.
I'm glad you got it.
But yeah, we really do care that it has the tire mark on it.
In the podcast, we recorded yesterday, actually, and I called it...
I called it a skid mark.
And...
And Matara was just like, what?
What did you say?
Why did you call it that?
Do you know what that means?
I was like, what are you talking about?
Like a...
Like a skid mark on the road.
Like a tire skid mark.
She was like, that's not what that means.
And I had to, like, look it up mid-recording.
I was like, yes, that is what that means.
It literally...
The first definition of it was a...
Like a tire skid mark.
I can't...
I can't live like this anymore, you guys.
I can't keep...
I can't keep not really like this.
I swear to God.
I swear.
This is happening everyday in my afterlife.
I can't do this anymore.
I can't.
I can't keep living in paranoia.
Of everything.
What else are you supposed to say?
Tire marks, like guys?
I don't know...
I guess?
I don't know!
I can't...
I just...
I didn't know.
I can't believe you raw-talked that skinmark line.
Shut up!
Raw-talking lines without her prediction.
What is a skinmark then?
It's apparently like... I don't want to say it.
It's gross.
If you google skinmarks, the first definition was like a tire mark on the road.
And then the second was the definition that she was thinking of.
I just...
I never think of that!
Doo-doo residue.
Doo-doo resi-doo-doo.
Resi-doo-doo.
That's what it...
Just don't turn on google image search.
Okay, so...
Funny that you mentioned that because
for some reason when I look stuff up, I like instinctually go to google images.
I don't know why.
But I was like laughing because there was like a board game or something.
Like a children's game that was called skinmarks or something.
And you play as a dog that were like...
You put like a brown pencil in it.
And it's like a drawing game.
And I'm just scared.
I can't.
I can't!
And like the dog like scoots around on its butt.
But doesn't that mean like it has worms and stuff?
It's just so...
Oh god.
Hold on, I'll take a sippy.
The things they make for children are truly abhorrent sometimes, I swear.
Okay, I'm gonna go choke this guy.
Oh!
We're fine!
He's dead.
Just run away.
There we go.
We're fine!
Everything's fine.
Don't worry about it.
I always run into them when I'm trying to choke them out, I swear.
Spend your afterlife frog-dogging urban dictionary... Stop it!
I'm not gonna... What, do I need like an urban dictionary stream?
I swear.
Okay.
I always run into them when I'm choking them.
But it's okay.
We got him.
Tried Gakuenmash yet?
Gakuenmash?
No!
I haven't tried it yet.
This one was safe, right?
Oh good, good, good.
Wait, is this...
Oh, no.
And then this guy comes down this way, right?
Yeah.
And he looks up.
Oh!
Okay.
So we're gonna go to... Oh, wait.
Was anything level 2?
I don't think so.
Speaking of the board game, the Metal Gear Solid board game ships...
Oh, yes!
Yes, I know, I know!
I'm so excited for it.
Just waiting for him to leave.
Waiting for this guy to leave.
Go away, so I can take the elevator, please.
Snake!
I took a one step!
I took one step!
That's insanity.
Oh my god.
I cannot believe that actually happened.
Can I get the... Wait, what else can I get here?
I can't remember.
Ha.
Ha, ha.
Ha, indeed.
Ha.
Normal people are like the dictionary.
La, la, la.
Back it up, back it up, back it up, baby.
Yeah, these ones are... these ones don't move.
Okay.
Alright, Snake.
There you go, there you go.
Nice and easy, nice and easy.
Okay, now he comes down.
Okay.
Woo, woo, woo.
We can probably take this guy out then.
Oh, shoot!
Oh, thank you.
We're fine.
Don't, don't come in here.
I swear.
Yeah, return to your position!
Oh, man.
They reset.
I should've just shot him, shouldn't I?
Oh.
Okay, now I have to wait.
Actually, which way does this... does he go down or does he go up?
He goes up, right?
Ugh.
Stealth, you guys, I swear.
Ha, ha, ha.
Why do I even engage?
You know?
Ha, ha, ha.
Why do I even engage?
For fun.
Ha, ha, ha.
When do I get a box, man?
I feel so naked.
Okay, um...
Oh, my God.
Is it in here?
Ah, okay.
I was like, wait a second.
I think it actually is around here.
Yippee!
Oh.
I need more ration, though.
Yikes.
When will it let me hoard more?
I swear.
Ha, ha, ha.
Oh, gosh.
It's always this guy that really messes me up.
Ha, ha, ha.
He's always like, huh?
What was that noise?
There's someone else over here, right?
Huh?
What was that noise?
I see you.
In
fact, we'll just box it.
For now.
Sneaky.
Call people in the box, right?
Campbell, look!
Don't make too much noise or you'll be spotted.
Be careful when you're walking on that floor.
Oh, yeah.
I know.
Oh, I know.
Look, look, look!
Don't make too much noise or you'll be spotted.
Be careful when you're walking on that floor.
Colonel, Colonel!
I'm like a worm.
What have you got there?
A cardboard box?
Yeah!
Remember that trick?
That's the snake I remember.
Those poor fools won't know what hit them.
I know.
Actually, probably Nastasha has a ton of info.
Let's let her info dump for a second.
A cardboard box.
A cardboard box usually consists of a thin pasteboard...
I don't care.
...and a paper center.
They are usually made of recycled paper.
Paper?
It was first invented in Europe over a hundred years ago.
A cardboard box?
It was originally used to absorb one's sweat when wearing hats.
Wait, really?
With the same amount of wood to make one wooden box, you can make six or seven cardboard boxes.
And since it's recyclable, it's highly economical.
In addition, it's strong and easy to throw.
That's why it's widely used for packing.
But to avoid damaging weapons and other delicate instruments when shipping them, they should be packed in stronger boxes Stronger boxes?
Also, the crevices should be filled with styrofoam to prevent them from moving around.
Her accents are great.
Anyway, what's with the box?
I just like it.
Oh, nothing.
No big deal.
She mansplains the cardboard box to me and then she's like, so, why are you in it?
And he's like...
He gets embarrassed about it.
Master!
A cardboard box, huh?
Just like Sandsiborg.
It can save my skin more than a few times in Outer Heaven 2.
Getting the maximum use out of ordinary on-hand objects is the first principle of survival.
It's especially important in covert operations.
I haven't forgotten what you taught me.
Master, you've taught me so much.
You've taught me so much, Master!
First, the DARPA chief.
And then President Baker die of a heart attack?
Yeah, it's really sus, man.
Smells pretty rotten to me.
Master, do you know anything?
No.
But there's definitely something going on.
Keep your eyes open out there.
Okay.
My eyes are peeled.
Gamble.
The DARPA chief and President Baker.
So now the terror know both detonation codes.
So they can launch at any time.
And on top of that, they both died right in front of my eyes.
Snake, now that the terrorists have both detonation codes, the only way to stop a nuclear launch is to either use the detonation code release keys that Meryl's holding, or...
find the Metal Gear chief engineer that President Baker mentioned.
Hal Emmerich!
In any case, you should contact Meryl by codec.
Wasn't her frequency written on the back of the CD case?
Yes, we're out of there now.
I totally forgot!
Let's contact Meryl.
The back of the CD case.
140.15 Who
are you?
I was really impressed with the way you busted yourself out of there.
The one from the prison?
You're the Colonel's niece.
Meryl, right?
No, it's not him.
Then just exactly who are you?
I'm the fool that your uncle sent all alone into the middle of this whole mess.
You came by yourself?
You think you're some kind of one-man army?
I don't need lectures.
You're just like your uncle, you know?
How do you know my uncle?
We go way back.
What's your name?
My name's not important.
Could you be Snake?
Are you Solid Snake?
That's what some people call me.
The legendary Solid Snake?
You?
Sorry about before.
I wasn't sure if you were one of the good guys.
But I knew you were.
How?
It's your eyes.
My eyes?
They're not soldiers' eyes.
They're rookies' eyes, right?
No, they're beautiful, compassionate eyes.
Just what I'd expect from the legendary Solid Snake.
Stop that, Snake.
She's had psychotherapy.
Don't worry.
You'll land back on them once you meet me.
The reality is no match for the legend.
I'm afraid.
Oh, I don't believe that.
Why did you look so surprised when you saw my face?
Because you look just like him.
You mean the terrorist leader, Liquid Snake?
Yeah.
You know him?
You're not brothers, are you?
I have no family.
So what's the deal then?
Why would he look just like me then?
But first I want some information.
You were involved in this exercise from the beginning.
What exactly happened here?
I'm sorry.
President Baker, right after the terrorist attack.
That's okay.
But what is this place?
I don't think it's just a nuclear weapons disposal facility.
Boy oh boy.
It's just like them.
Nobody told you anything, did they?
Nope.
You see, this place isn't really for disposing nuclear weapons.
What?
This base is owned and operated by a dummy corporation of arms.
This is a civilian base?
Right.
For the development of Metal Gear.
Metal Gear?
Colonel.
Colonel, why didn't you say anything?
We're called here for the test launching of a dummy nuclear warhead.
Oh my god.
Why Foxhound?
Because they're a special ops group used to handling top secret missions.
They figured they could help keep it all hush hush.
But we must have fired nuclear warheads before.
Why just this time?
Title drop?
There's gonna be a lot of those.
There's gonna be a whole lot of those.
This whole thing is fishy, huh?
This whole thing is fishy.
Well, we know what they want.
They want Big Boss' DN-A.
They want his body.
They're gonna get his body back.
XD He's dead...
What?
sometimes.
Yeah, it's really... it's really suspicious!
Hal!
Yeah!
I'm sorry, I'm on a first-name basis with him.
I'm like, oh, you know, Hal, we'll be right back.
No.
I've watched Second Floor Basement.
Taking a shot every time they mention Metal Gear.
Oh gosh, Loda, please!
A shirt attack.
Oh no, I just realized we're gonna have to fight the tank.
I forgot about that.
Uh...
Five!
Can you give it to me?
No way!
Jose?
That's true.
I don't know what happened, I just couldn't pull the trigger right away.
I never had any problems in training.
But when I thought about my bullets tearing through those soldiers' bodies, I hesitated.
Shooting at targets and shooting at living, breathing people are different.
Ever since I was a little girl, I always dreamed about being a soldier.
Every day of my life, I've trained my mind and body for the one day when I could finally see some real action.
And now...
So what now?
You wanna quit?
I can't quit.
I can't allow myself to quit now.
Listen, Meryl.
Everybody feels sick the first time they kill someone.
Yikes.
Unfortunately, killing is one of those things that gets easier the more you do it.
In a war, all of mankind's worst emotions, worst traits come out.
It's easy to forget what a sin is in the middle of a battlefield.
But this isn't a war.
It's a terrorist action.
You're just a little jumpy from the cutscene.
It's still combat high.
Yeah, it's still combat, though.
The adrenaline in your bloodstream is starting to thin out.
Just take it easy.
But I learned all about combat high at the academy.
We'll talk about it later.
For now, just think about keeping yourself alive.
If I get out of here alive, I'll think about that other stuff.
Because they don't have it in the Twin Snakes?
Let me try to say this another way.
It's like so...
Stay the hell out of my way.
Ugh.
You're a real bastard.
Just like my uncle said.
I told you.
The real me is no match for the legend.
It looks like you were right.
Okay, Snake.
I'll be a good girl.
We'll link up after I grab the doctor.
Then we'll take care of the detonation code override.
Gotcha.
But listen.
I know this area better than you.
Call me if you have any questions.
Be careful, okay?
You said you'd be a good girl.
Open the cargo door.
I'll contact you.
Okay.
Open the car- uh...
Open the door for me.
The cargo door for me.
That guy's right there.
I know I gotta go get some thermal goggles.
They're in that one right there, right?
Up there?
Or is it the night vision?
If I walk, the guy below will hear me.
So, hold on.
Actually, I'll just crawl.
You can't get them now?
You can only get them after the tank.
Oh, so I have to use the cigarettes?
Okay, we'll just chill then.
We'll just wait for her to open the door.
What's the one in that room?
Oh, downstairs.
I can go in there though, right?
Oh, already?
Snake, I unlocked the cargo door for you.
Yippee!
Thanks.
Where are you?
Where I can see ya.
Don't move around too much.
Don't worry.
I'm disguised in this enemy uniform.
You won't be for long with the way you walk.
What does that mean?
Nothing.
Listen, Snake.
The cargo door is like an airlock.
Don't worry about it.
It's equipped with infrared sensors.
Be careful.
Too late for the goggles?
How is it too late?
If an intruder ascends, gas is released.
Gas?
Gas.
Okay, so we'll meet at the nuclear warhead storage building.
Hey, you said you'd be a good girl.
You said you'd stay put and be a good girl.
I changed my mind.
That was fast.
Don't get careless.
That's when things always turn sour.
Sorry, but this is the only way I can figure out whether or not I'm cut out to be a soldier.
Wait, but it's not too late.
These guys are professionals.
You're going to get yourself killed.
See you there.
Oh, it's a glitch to get it?
That's not fair.
That's not real.
Oh, my God.
One time, I was playing this game.
And I was down there in that room, in the one below.
That one.
And I got killed.
Or no, I didn't get killed.
I triggered an alert as the cargo door was opening.
And so it, like, mid-cutscene, closed the cargo door.
As I was like...
As I was trying to, um...
As I was trying to, like...
I was in cutscene, but the guy was, like, shooting at me.
It was so funny.
Oh, gosh.
I need more ration.
I think I will try and get the suppressor, though.
It would probably be good to have.
Oh, I think it might be good to have.
Probably.
Wait, does that guy walk over this way?
Yes.
We're just going to hold out.
We're going to hold out.
That guy is right there.
He might hear my footsteps.
We're going to let for him...
Wait for him to go away.
A little bit.
Oh, my God.
He's right there.
He was right there.
I thought he left.
Oh, my gosh.
Is he gone?
Clearly, he's blind.
And...
Oh.
Why did you turn?
I forgot that it...
That it...
That it, like...
Wait.
My box.
I forgot that it, like, shows up.
You know?
Wait, do I have to call her again?
Shoot.
Yes, I do.
Hold on.
I have to look at the back of the box.
140.15.
It's already there.
Oh, wait.
Oh, no.
It's at...
I can't even read.
So, now the terrorists know both detonation codes.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think we...
I think we did this one.
Okay.
Mooned.
Oh.
Uh.
No, no.
Oh, it's fine.
In any case, you should contact Meryl by codec.
Wasn't her frequency rated?
No.
Okay.
Here we go.
15.
I have to look at it every time, you guys.
Also, I'm not good at remembering codec numbers.
I'm going to skip all this because we went through it.
So, don't worry about it.
Do we got to go upstairs for an item again?
Yeah.
But it's okay because we have to wait for the...
For her to open the door anyway.
So...
Okay.
Let's see.
What we were talking
about?
Second floor basement.
Be a good girl.
Okay.
Where is that guy, anyway?
Can't believe that guy saw my box.
Kind of annoyed about that.
Okay.
That's kind of annoying, he saw my box.
I'm kind of annoyed by that.
Slow and steady.
Don't move.
Gosh, you scare me.
Right where I can see ya.
They're gonna find you out with that pretty touch of yours.
What do you mean by that?
I showed you my box, please respond.
Oh, there he is.
I think we can avoid this guy.
Yeah, nice.
Oh, he's gonna see me now though, isn't he?
No, he went the other way.
Yeah, we're all good.
But there's another guy around here.
Where is he?
There's a guy up there.
There's another guy.
Oh, the one tank is gone.
It's only just the one guy, right?
Okay, never mind.
And then we go in here and there's a guy.
I have to be careful though.
He's asleep.
Okay.
Guys, I always die here.
I'm scared.
I always die here.
But I want the suppressor.
Stealthy choke.
Stealthy.
I'm assuming you didn't mean to let them see your box.
She really didn't know I'm sorry, society.
What are you talking about?
You got this, boss?
Okay.
I'm preparing myself.
I'm going in for the hug.
Okay.
I'm being a little creep.
Yeah!
Okay.
Time to go fight...
some other stuff.
Meow!
Poison gas?
Okay.
Why'd she take off the mask?
I don't know.
Maybe so we can hear her better.
Who knows?
Okay.
Oh, nope.
Do I have to...
Do I have to equip it?
I can't remember.
Do I have to like...
There we go.
Nice.
Okay.
Just so I don't forget that.
Cigarettes.
Oh my god.
Maybe I should use a ration.
I'm scared.
Oh, it's not going down.
So bad.
Oh my god.
Please.
Please, Snake.
I can't see...
I can't see the one in front of me.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Alright.
Down.
Up.
Okay.
And...
Down.
Yeah!
Try calling.
Hey, Meryl.
I got through.
Be careful, Snake.
That airlock is set with infrared sensors.
Snakes don't belong in Alaska.
I did it!
Colonel!
It looks like the place is protected by infrared sensors.
You probably didn't know, but box is a euphemism.
Somehow you'll have to make it past the beams.
For who?
People who have been through war...
Then what do you mean...
It's a box!
Chill out!
Trust your instincts as a soldier.
As a gamer.
As a gamer!
Hahaha!
Yeah!
Snake, that room is set with infrared sensors.
You should be able to see them if you had some smoke.
Cigarette smoke or something.
You would suggest that, wouldn't you, Nastasha?
Sorry, but these are smokeless cigarettes.
You mean those cigarettes that are designed to cut down on secondary smoke?
Is that a real thing?
Oh, well.
If you blow the smoke in the direction of the infrared sensors, you should be able to see them.
That was a good idea, bringing the cigarettes.
But don't smoke too much.
Cigarettes make you weak in mind and body.
They are bad for you.
She doesn't have a cigarette.
She has a lollipop.
Obviously.
I don't know why I'm saving.
I just want to hear her voice.
Oh, complete!
Snake, like Shakespeare said, knots had all spent, for our desire is got without content.
Basically, it means that your desire can get you into trouble if you're not careful.
I'm always careful.
Don't get too greedy or you might be sorry.
Be careful, Snake.
See, she's telling me not to go for the goggles, you guys.
I don't need it.
Hong Mei Ling.
No, no, no.
No, no.
I didn't get a mind detector.
Wait, where do you get the mind detector at?
Uh-oh.
Or is it not yet?
No, it is now, right?
Yeah, we'll just crawl.
We're fine, guys.
We're fine.
There's like, what, six of them here or something?
Who could that be?
I don't have that!
Who are you?
Deep Throat.
Deep Throat?
The informant from the Watergate scandal?
Never mind about that.
You're not using burst transmission.
Are you nearby?
Listen, there's a tank in front of your position waiting to ambush you.
Who are you anyway?
Don't worry about it.
He's one of my fans!
I'm gonna collect them right now.
They're around here.
I got them.
Hold on.
One.
Look how little life I have left, you guys.
It's so bad.
Maybe I should go back and get the mind detector, shouldn't I?
Where is it at?
I got it!
The goggles floor?
Second floor?
Okay.
Is there another ration over here?
I crawl because I don't remember.
Okay, let's go back.
The sensors are turned off now though, right?
And the claymores are right next to each other, so...
Okay, but here I can save.
Mei Ling.
How can someone outside of this operation cut into my codec?
Oh yeah, that's right.
I should ask them.
You're talking about that guy calling himself Deep Throat.
We were monitoring from here.
What about it?
Well, if somebody knows your frequency, they can call you.
But the question is, how did he learn it?
It's top secret information.
Can you tell me where he called from?
I'm sorry.
The signal was too weak to locate a source.
We have a leak.
But I'm sure he's near you.
We have a rat!
Somewhere on the base.
Save.
We've got a rat here!
You know what, I will do a new file.
It's fine though.
Be careful, Snake.
Deep Throat being a wisp.
14066 for an integral bonus?
Really?
1466?
Press cancel button to exit.
Music frequencies?
No way!
Oh my god!
So cool!
I'll be honest.
Though, I don't remember the Metal Gear 2 theme.
I don't think I would have recognized it if you guys hadn't told me.
Because I...
Really, the only song I remember...
Unless I heard it again.
I think because it's not...
What's it called?
I think because it's like a...
Not...
From the game.
But I mostly remember just...
Theme of Tara.
But yeah.
Cool!
Thanks for the little Easter egg!
Thank you!
Okay, let's go back and get the...
Mind detector.
Oh, I should also call everybody.
Hold on.
Canyon!
That was really cool though!
Snake, you'll have to go through the minefield to advance.
Oh, thanks.
Okay.
Thanks for your wisdom.
Master!
Master, does the name Deep Throat mean anything to you?
Oh boy.
Deep Throat?
That's what they call me at the club.
You mean the guy from Watergate?
No, but he uses the same name.
Snatcher or Policenauts.
Whoever he is, he's not part of our operation.
But he's been giving me advice by Kodak.
I know them.
I have not played them.
I have not spoiled myself on them either.
On top of that, he wasn't using burst transmission.
It seems he was transmitting from somewhere on this base.
Because I intend on playing them.
Somewhere on the base?
Yes.
I have no idea who that could be.
I see.
No idea!
Hey Meryl, do you know Deep Throat or...
Is that harassment if I ask her that?
No.
Oh!
She even tells me.
NISTASHA!
NISTASHA INFAMOUSLY OFF TOPIC.
We call her and she's just like...
Something's going on.
Everyone's talking about Sniper Wolf.
And she'll be like...
Nuclear materials are harming everything.
Shit.
Sorry, I breathed wrong.
What was I saying?
I don't remember.
Anyway, sorry.
It's a really, really good lollipop.
Sorry, I breathed wrong.
You know when you like breathe wrong and you like...
Half swallow your spit wrong?
That's what just happened to me.
I don't need...
I don't need the things though anymore, right?
I don't need the cigarettes.
Oh no, I do, I do, I do.
Oh goodness gracious.
Good thing I did it.
Oh my god.
Oh my god, oh my god...
Nice nice.
Dang it I really should've gone all the way over there then.
I feel silly not having gone.
Do you think we can take this guy out?
Let's attempt.
Clean.
CLEAN.
revelation CLOCK.
Oh, never mind.
Is there a... wait.
Is there anything under here?
Nope.
Okay.
It's truly the other side that I have to worry about though.
Oh, go, go, go, go, snake!
Go, go, go!
It's the other side that always freaks me out more.
But at least we don't have some guy downstairs being like...
Being like, what was that noise?
When they hear me walking across.
You can shoot the other guy with your...
Oh my gosh, I think you're right.
Wait, can I shoot him from here?
Can I shoot him from here?
This may be far.
What about now?
He's gonna see me though.
Where is he?
Oh, he's all the way over there.
I think you can from that range.
Okay.
Is he gonna see me?
Okay, we'll see if he can see my box first.
Just a box!
Just a box.
He doesn't come over here though, right?
Oh, he does.
He does.
Does he continue over here?
I think I'm gonna try.
Oh, no.
Oh.
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
I didn't get him.
Got him.
There we go.
Oh.
Perfect.
Yes.
Yippee!
I love killing!
Is there anything over there?
I can't remember.
It's probably not worth the risk.
Run away!
And we're free to run as freely as we want.
I enjoy the killing!
I love killing!
Kill!
All you need is kill.
Worst cameras in the world.
They can't see even two feet in front of them.
I'm adding more ghosts.
Run!
Is there anything else in here?
Now that I have free reign, I'm just gonna like...
We can go anywhere we want, baby.
Do I have enough grenades?
I got 12.
Okay.
I killed that guy in there even.
Continue onwards.
Okay, this one's fast.
Okay.
There we go.
Good, good, good.
This one's slow.
Sometimes it's hard to tell which is when...
Okay, this one is in front of me.
Okay.
Yippee!
Where's your thermal goggles?
I'll get them when I get them!
Good thing there are no radios in this game.
Oh my gosh, it's such a blessing.
That's why I'm afraid for...
for...
MGS2.
Yoink!
I can't remember.
Do I have to be...
behind it?
I'm just paranoid.
Yoink!
And...
Hold on, I'm gonna check this side too.
Nothing here.
Okay.
And...
Now you can be in front if you're crawling?
Okay, cool.
I can never remember.
There is one that you can't be in front of it, right?
Or am I going crazy?
Yoink!
Yay!
More claymores!
And that should be all of them.
Okay.
Wait, there's nothing here, right?
Whoa!
I have such a bad habit of like...
stopping two steps before...
before the thing is supposed to occur.
I'm just fine.
Okay, that's it.
That's it.
He's gonna say it.
Snakes don't belong in Alaska.
Yeah!
Send him a message.
Watch out, snake!
He's so cool.
I love that line.
That's right.
You belong on the ground.
Vulcan raven!
You should crawl on the ground like the snake you are.
Come, let's fight!
I gotta get close.
Oh, shit!
Don't laugh at me!
Don't laugh at me, Vulcan raven.
Come on.
Don't laugh at me.
I'm doing my best, okay?
I'm just a little snake.
Oh, my God!
How am I supposed to get close to him?
Oh, the chaps!
I think I'm okay.
Yeah!
Invincibility firm!
Oh, my God!
It wasn't soon enough!
No!
Oh, my gosh!
Did I get it?
Guys!
Ouch!
Oh, come on.
That should have worked.
Don't run over me, please.
Yoink!
I said don't run over me, but like...
If
I die to this, it'll be pretty funny.
I'm not gonna lie.
This is so dumb.
Oh!
I literally...
Oh, I love this part.
Oh, wait.
No, I think I'm thinking of...
Twin Snakes.
Just kidding.
Wasn't it three waves?
Guess not.
Maybe in Twin Snakes it was.
Well, boss.
I hope you are happy.
There he goes.
You got the car.
We played with him a little longer.
He sounds so disappointed.
I'm warning.
It would be wise not to underestimate him.
He got the car.
What did you think of him?
He is just as you said.
In battle, he is as if possessed by a demon.
Ghost.
Much like you.
I would expect no less.
You see?
I told you so.
But I will kill him.
So, General Ivan.
I hear he took your hand as well as you.
I hope you are happy.
Watch your tongue, Shaman.
Shaman!
In the language of the Sioux people, Sioux means snake.
Sioux.
It is known as an animal to be feared.
Well, snake is mine now.
When I meet him next, I'll take special care of him.
Not yet.
My.
He and I will meet again in battle.
Oh, yes, we will.
Addiction as always.
Yes.
The raven on my head.
It thirsts for blood.
Wait, I wanna go...
Yimmy.
Defeat the M1 tank.
Yeah.
Let's get this ration over here.
In this building, we cannot use weapons.
I wanna go back out there and get some stuff.
They don't install the cameras and stuff immediately, right?
Level 3 car, let's go!
Call people.
I will, thank you.
But I will after we do this.
Okay, good.
I'm just going to have the mine detector equipped just in case.
I don't remember if there actually were any rations around here.
But...
Oh, is that one?
Yes.
Oh, thank goodness.
Wait, I want to see that view.
Wow, so cool!
So cool, so cool.
It's so cinematic.
Can you finish off the raven guy now?
I think he flew away.
I think he's like... gone, gone.
Can I take over the tank?
I wonder.
That'd be pretty... pretty nifty.
I just charge into the nuclear warhead building in my tank.
Newly acquired tank.
No worries.
Album cover?
Truly!
It is really like an album cover, right?
You're pretty good at this game?
You think so?
No, stop it.
Don't get my hopes up.
Just wait until MGS2, I promise.
Actually, no.
Wait until...
Psycho Mantis.
Wait until Psycho Mantis and then see if I'm good at this game anymore.
Now I can hold three rations!
Yippee!
Wait, we had one the whole time?
Did I accidentally unequip it?
Is that what happened?
Am I a silly goose?
Am I a silly... willy?
Did I accidentally... oh my god.
Can I, like, hide first?
A silly ghost?
Oh, I just got two.
Okay, good.
Gravy!
We're all warheads?
They just leave them here?
It's like President Baker said.
Totally careless.
They're working on a limited budget.
They try to put on a pretty face for the media, but this is the grim reality of it.
But...
Nastasha knows lots more about it than I do.
I have no, like, protective anything.
All of the warheads in those boxes have had their detonation mechanisms removed, so there's no fear of them exploding.
But, like...
But if the warheads are broken, they might leak plutonium, and that would be a serious problem.
I'm gonna be... I'm gonna grow a second arm.
Never use your weapon on that floor.
Maybe even a third arm.
Who knows?
Okay, hold on.
Let me get in my box and go over here for a second.
Okay, there he is.
You see, they get protective stuff, but not me.
Don't move.
Just a box.
Thanks, Faralette.
You sent the thing.
What have you got there?
A cardboard box?
Oh, I forgot to do this codec.
Yeah, remember that.
Hold on, we'll skip through it.
We did it earlier, in case you were like, why'd you skip it?
We already did it.
Snake, you've got to rescue Dr. Emmerich, the Metal Gear Engineer.
The Metal Gear Engineer.
He's probably being held prisoner in the second-floor basement of the warhead storage building.
He's got a fun ring to it.
Snake, never use your weapon on that floor.
I'm not gonna listen to you.
What can I do for you, Snake?
Second-floor basement?
Why is everybody in the second-floor basement?
Snake, in China they say you must cross the river before you tell the crocodile he has bad breath.
Do you know what that means?
It means that the wise man avoids danger first.
Use your brain to avoid traps and stay away from the enemy.
A cardboard box.
Oh, we heard this one too.
Sorry.
What's with the box?
NBD.
NBD!
Snake, that is a nuclear warhead storage area.
I know.
I must never use a weapon there.
Yes, but their detonation mechanisms have been removed.
So I don't have to worry about this island turning into a pile of smoking rubble.
No, but if the casing is damaged, they may be leaking nuclear materials.
Please, make sure you do not use your gun around there.
Um, I'm more concerned about my body.
Like, if it's leaking nuclear materials, am I going to be okay?
I am exposed!
Excuse me!
A cardboard box, huh?
Oh, we did this one.
Sorry, I forgot that we're gonna get the cardboard box a bajillion times.
In war, a split second can mean the difference between victory and defeat.
Don't ever hesitate.
Okay.
The slower you react, the greater the chance that you'll be beaten.
Thank you, Master.
Thank you.
A cardboard box?
I heard stories from my uncle, but I always thought he was pulling my leg.
I've got no comment.
Okay.
Wow.
Thanks, I guess.
Very insightful.
Deep Throat, do you have anything to say about my cardboard box?
I thought you were one of my fans.
I thought you would like my box.
I thought you said you were one of my fans.
Should I put a... I'm stuck on the wall?
Wait.
Oh, there he is!
He comes down and around.
I'll wait for him to go around.
Show you my box, please respond.
No, don't respond.
Don't look... don't look in my direction.
Don't even notice...
Oh.
Just a box.
Continue on your merry way.
Where's the guy upstairs?
Oh gosh, this is difficult.
Oh god, I can't see at all.
There we go.
I think I just gotta go.
This guy doesn't come down the stairs, alright?
Okay.
Turn around.
Say there, you're good?
Okay.
Thank you.
Like I said, I couldn't remember if he came downstairs or not.
And he stops... somewhere.
And then he goes to the left.
Yes.
Books!
Oh!
Wait, I've gotta go to... oh wait, I've gotta go to B2.
Two, so then I can be like, oh my god!
Two!
Thank you!
I started saying, me dominto, like, side-o-chest-o, and I can't stop.
Yeah, we gotta go here so we can be like, oh my god, it's gas!
We gotta get the Nikita missile!
Nikita missile time!
Gosh, the music in here is so... awesome.
Danger, danger.
Leaning on Otacon's wall is fine.
Oh yes, we should do that.
And I'm gonna knock on it.
Oh my gosh, we're gonna get that seed!
Ah, hold on!
I can't breathe!
Cardo!
Deep throat!
You destroyed the high-voltage switch.
It's the switchboard on the northwest wall.
It really didn't want Otacon getting out.
For now, I can't reach it.
Use a remote-controlled missile.
Okay!
I gotta let me out so I can breathe!
Okay.
So we have to go...
First, we gotta talk to him.
Do-do-do-do!
Hey!
Hey-hey-hey!
Do-do-do-do!
I can't wait for that scene with Liquid.
When he goes do-do-do-do!
Okay, uh, let's call everybody and they are gonna tell me to go back all the way to the, uh...
To the... that other... basement.
B2 basement.
For the time being, let's trust what Deep Throat told us.
Use a remote-controlled missile to destroy the switchboard in the northwest section of the Warhead Storage Building's second floor basement.
Make sure your remote-controlled missile doesn't get shot down by those gun cameras.
Okay...
Master... at the back trap...
I have a question.
Could I have just gone in?
Wait, should I... could I have just gone and got it?
And then... done the... cutscene?
And already had the Nikita missile?
Yes.
Yeah, once you have the level 3 card...
It's okay.
We're... we're doing it like we've never played the game before.
Oh wait, yeah.
We're... we're...
I did that on my playthrough.
We're... we're being accurate as if we have never played the game before.
First playthrough roleplay.
Yeah, exactly.
The intended path.
Turn around?
Turn around...
Oh, nope.
This is... it's for the authentic first-timer experience.
Experience.
Satsugaminto.
Yeah!
Now
and then I get a little bit lonely And you're never coming round Turn around Every now and then I get a little bit tired Of listening to the sound of my toes Turn around Every now and then I get a little bit something That the best of all our years have gone by Turn around Every now and then I get a little...
And then I see the look in your eye Turn around For right eyes Every now and then I fall apart Turn around For right eyes Every now and then I fall apart And I need you now, tonight And I need you more than ever And if you only hold me tight We'll be holding on forever And you'll only be making it right Cause you'll never be brought to...
U.S.
nuclear warheads and wastes have never been left neglected, with very few exceptions.
Oh.
Cool.
Anyway, enjoy.
Thanks for the... thanks for the tip.
You're pretty good.
Huey.
Hi Huey.
Wait, so now it's turned off though, right?
And the other tank is gone, right?
Unless, wait.
The tank that I just shot down was the one that they used.
Never mind.
Thanks for the super chat.
Huey.
It's turned off now though, right?
Please say yes.
No!
Why?
This is so cruel.
At least it's like kind of easy to get to the...
To the elevator from here.
But I gotta get the thermal goggles.
I know, I gotta get the thermal goggles.
Someone's gotta go get the thermal goggles.
Where is that guy?
Oh, there he is.
Oh gosh, oh gosh, oh gosh.
He can't see me though, right?
I'm kinda pretty good at that.
Thanks for the super chat!
There's a super...
Sorry, I didn't mean to pause it like that.
There's a super neat show called Over the Garden.
Wow, I think you'd really like it.
We should all watch it later this fall.
I love that!
I love that show.
Thanks for the super chat.
We should watch it.
That singing got me melting like Tuskaku.
I think you need level 4.
Okay, never mind.
Can anybody attest to that?
Oh wait.
I always press that instead of...
Can I see it from here?
It is 4!
You can see it from down here.
It says 4.
I think.
It says...
4.
It says 4.
You saved me.
You really saved me.
Thank you, thank you.
Whoever said that.
Okay.
Second floor basement.
And don't get caught in here.
Okay.
Wait, unless you get it at the beginning of the game before the DARPA Chief.
How do you get it?
Is it actually a glitch or is it just like something...
Way to get it.
Guys, I don't remember at all which one have the .
Remember, earlier, I was like we should look at these and memorize which one is what.
No, it's the front middle one.
Because the top left one was the PSG.
Top middle was the Nikita.
Which means we're going to have to come all the way back here.
The door is four but open before the...
Okay, okay, okay.
The thermal goggles door is open if you enter the hangar from the top vent.
Oh, I never go through the top vent.
That's why I don't know.
I never go through the top vent.
I'm just going to wait for these guys to leave.
Can they hear me?
Can they hear me footsteps?
Wait a second.
Okay, we're going to go this way instead.
Don't drop and die.
That was close.
That was really close.
It's this one.
I don't trust it.
Wait, this is the C4!
Where is the Nikita missile then?
Wait, it's B1 of the nuclear storage.
I thought it was in here.
Wait, I thought it was in here.
Why did I come all the way back then?
I thought it was in the other building.
What?
It's in both.
Oh my god.
I knew I... Oh, I misremembered.
It's always the dang card levels that get me.
Are you kidding me?
You did the same in the third season?
It's always the card levels that get me.
No, so it's a level 4 card here.
Oh my god, hold on.
No way.
That's so funny.
It gets me every time.
First time playing!
Why didn't you guys stop me from leaving the building then?
Oh my gosh.
I'm a silly goose.
Wait!
Is it this one?
I can't remember.
La la la la la.
You guys, we can do either one.
Gosh.
Don't scare me like that.
You guys.
Oh my gosh.
I thought so.
I'm not crazy.
Sometimes.
All the time.
Come on, elevator.
You were just here.
No one used it.
But we'll have to come back here again anyway because we have to get the PSG.
Do do do.
Do do.
Saving.
La la la la.
Come
on, everybody.
I'm just a simple...
Oh, I almost went.
Thinking that it was...
Done-zo.
Wait, I can't see it.
Oh, there it is.
Okay.
Nice and slow.
Fast.
Thinking
you kept those cigarettes in your stomach.
Stummy-ciggies.
Your stamina, physique must be in top condition to actually walk around a car by bike.
Or a cardboard box like that.
Right?
You were crouched the whole time.
It's actually quite impressive the way that...
Gosh, I wish these would respawn.
It's really impressive the way Snake can actually run with it.
I mean, that's why he's...
Oh, I just real...
Sorry, I just noticed my cursor.
That's why he's like the greatest...
He's the legend.
He's a legend!
That's why his butt's so big.
The cardboard box is like bopping up and down against his fat ass as he runs.
My fat ass.
Mei Ling.
My cake is just too thick.
It's clapping.
How's it going, Snake?
Have you gotten used to using the radar yet?
I think so.
Yeah, it's a great system.
Not only can I read the topography, but I can monitor the movement of the bad guys, too.
So awesome.
Pretty convenient, huh?
It also makes it easy for us to see everything that you're doing.
You're watching everything?
Of course.
If you were my boyfriend, you'd never be able to cheat on me.
Being monitored 24 hours a day, that'd be like hell.
Don't think of it like that.
What are you trying to do, huh, Snake?
At least you'd never get lost.
You don't want people to monitor you for, huh?
What are you doing?
For the time being, let's trust what Deepthroat told us.
I am.
Use a remote-controlled missile.
Yeah, Warhead stor- oh.
Oh no!
It says to destroy the switchboard in the northwest section of the Warhead.
Okay, okay.
I was like, wait a second.
The Warhead storage building.
Second floor basement.
No, that's where we were!
That's where it's at, you guys!
Gosh.
Oh my gosh.
I lived near a nuclear facility as a kid and recently found out they kept all the enriched uranium in a six-year-old wooden warehouse!
You're Spider-Man.
I think.
Probably.
They say that there are 500,000 nuclear engineers in the world.
How can you watch Golden Girls if someone's watching?
After the end of the Cold War, the demands for nuclear engineers dropped precipitously.
In the Eastern Bloc countries in particular, there is a tremendous brain drain.
That's me.
Every day.
I have a brain drain.
And each year, more and more nuclear engineers go to work for the highest bidder.
That was me last night in the collab with Doki.
True brain drain.
When you're trying to hide, avoid places that look like the enemy might search.
Think about how your enemy is going to move and then sneak in there.
Doesn't matter how smart you are.
Just use your brain.
Use your head out there.
Are you telling me I'm dumb, Master?
What do you mean by that?
Deep throat?
No, I don't know anyone who calls himself that.
I see.
I wonder why he's trying to help you.
I have no idea.
A trap?
Could be.
But for the time being, I'll have to trust him.
Okay, bye.
Here we go.
I've got to get the other box in there too.
It's in there, right?
But most crucially for stealth...
Box.
Where's the other guy?
There's a guy up there.
Where's the guy that loops around?
Oh, there he is.
Hello.
Oh gosh, the sound of their footsteps is just true ASMR.
Is that like feet ASMR confirmed?
Oh no, I love feet ASMR.
Like, uh...
Have you guys ever listened to the...
The...
The way they walk in Barbie movies?
It's so crisp.
It's so like...
It's just...
It just really hits the spot.
Like I said, it's just so like...
Oh,
wrong button.
There we go.
I swear if you look up like...
If you look up like Barbie movie...
Footstep sounds...
I'm sure there's a video of it.
It's like...
It's a popular thing that people talk about.
I promise.
The Barbie...
Feet are what everybody is on about.
I swear.
Took huge psychic damage yesterday...
When someone pointed out...
That after you make a joke...
Doki often repeats the joke.
And compared it to...
No way, really?
Nah.
Also, Nano.
I saw that you started clipping the...
Twin snakes.
Do you plan on doing...
All the Metal Gear games?
If so...
I'm really sorry.
I'm really really...
Solid bird.
What a terrible name.
Alright, hold on.
Before we...
Oh shoot, I only have eight.
Press the X button.
And then I just let her rip.
Okay.
Oh gosh.
I forgot there's no first person.
Oh my god.
Now I remember.
Okay.
Go!
Don't get caught!
Yippee!
Run!
Okay.
Easy.
Easy peasy.
I remember when I couldn't ever even find that.
I'd be like... Where the hell is it?
Can I go in here?
Yes.
Yippee!
And the gas mask is in this one?
Nope.
The gas mask is in...
This one.
Should I chaff?
Okay, hold on.
I think I should chaff though, right?
Probably.
Let's chaff it up, bro.
Let's chaff it up!
Yippee!
I don't even know if I can go into the other ones.
The gas mask.
Oh come on!
I don't want to waste all my chaffs, bro.
Beep boop boop with the trap, you're so right.
I'm going
to kill myself.
Good, good, good, good, good, good.
You know what?
Let's just... let's just call it here.
Oh god.
Run, run, run!
Oh!
My gas mask!
I didn't get the other ration, though.
Oh...
You can blow up the cameras with Nikita.
You can?
Can you go upwards?
Excited for Delta?
I am...
super duper excited!
So, so, so excited!
Oh, come on.
That's cheap.
Oh, Stinger!
I was going to say, I don't think you can do it with the Nikita, right?
Oh, wait.
What does that say?
How's lab?
Keep out?
Wait, I've never noticed that before!
That's so funny.
How's lab?
Keep out!
And now for one of my favorite scenes...
in the whole...
game.
One of my favorite scenes...
in the whole, whole...
game.
Oh wait, I need a...
I love this part so much.
Oh, I love this part so...
much!
Okay, sorry.
I'm getting excited.
Hahaha!
It looks like...
they were cut by some type of blade.
What's this BL?
What's this?
...
Me!
It is me!
No!
Oh, so cool!
Oh my god, it's so freaky!
It's a ghost!
A brief moment when it turns into a horror game.
I know, it's so awesome!
It's that ninja!
Don't each of these bodies have a unique camera angle if you crouch next to them?
Oh, I'm not sure.
Oh my god, you're right!
What?
No way!
That's so cool!
Oh my god!
What?
Oh, is he still alive?
Are you okay, man?
I think I can save you.
Wait, one of them is still alive.
Him?
This guy is still alive.
You good?
You good, man?
I'm crawling.
I'll give you CPR!
Come here!
Oh yeah, he's even a little red dot.
Oh, sorry.
Don't use tongue when doing... Don't use tongue when...
Don't use tongue when applying CPR, everybody.
Oh my gosh, it's so cool.
Wow!
This is so awesome.
Oh my gosh, it's so freaky.
This is so cool.
Wow, thank you for teaching me about this.
I had no idea.
Oh my god, the way he died.
So sad.
It's so cool.
Oh, not that guy though.
He's not special.
He doesn't get his own.
Oh, there it is.
There it is.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think a specific character bloodstained later in the game does this as well.
Same with Johnny's naked body after...
Oh,
black void.
Okay, time for another fight that I struggle with sometimes.
But hopefully,
we've been doing okay on the boss fight so far.
In fact, I think the way...
Stealth camouflage?
Who are you?
Each time I've died, it's been by something stupid.
What are you talking about?
Oh, Otacon.
Little pee-pee pants man.
They're pee-pee their pants.
Ninja.
You're that ninja.
I've been waiting for you, Snake.
Who are you?
Pee-pee boy.
Neither enemy nor friend.
I am back from a world where such words are meaningless.
Ignore the voice actor.
I've removed all obstacles.
Now, you and I will battle to the death.
What do you want?
I've waited a long time for this day.
Now, I want to enjoy the moment.
What's with these guys?
Here it is.
It's like one of my Japanese animes.
I've come from another world to battle with you.
What is it?
Revenge?
Oh my god.
Is nothing so trivial as revenge?
Please not.
A fight to the death with you.
Only in that can my soul find its might.
Isn't it respite?
I will kill you, or you will kill me.
Respite?
It makes no difference.
I don't know, actually.
Fine.
You can watch from inside there.
I need that man.
Keep your hands off him.
God, sorry.
Now, make me feel it.
Hurt me more, Snake.
Make me feel alive again.
That's good, Snake.
Good.
Now we can fight as warriors.
Hand to hand.
It is the basis of all combat.
Only a fool trusts his life to a weapon.
I got you.
Hand to hand combat.
Where are you?
Come here.
Oh my god.
Ouch.
I'm going to die.
Oh, my god...
Run, run, run, run.
Oh my god.
He's got invincibility.
Oh, my god.
He's going crazy.
He's doing Cirque du Soleil flips over here.
Ouch!
Oh, my god.
He hits.
He packs a punch.
This fight is way...
I mean, all the fights are way easier in Twin Snakes, but this fight is way...
Oh my gosh.
Oh, my gosh.
He really hits hard.
She's really hard.
I
thought I wasn't going to make that one.
Come here.
There it is.
Okay.
Hurt me more.
I'm not good at this part.
Okay, never mind.
We know where he is.
Oh gosh, I'm on the other side of the room.
Don't come after me.
I'm coming.
I got you.
I got you first.
I got him first.
Do you think I hear him?
No, I don't.
Nice.
Nice and nice and nice.
I don't know where you are.
Where are you?
Can I keep punching him?
I think I keep punching him the whole time.
Where is he?
Oh, he's still walking.
Oh shit.
I forgot he did this.
Okay.
Hurt me more.
Oh, I forgot he teleported.
Okay.
Come here.
I couldn't predict.
Oh gosh.
Wait, did I already lose a...
Oh, yikes.
Hurt me more.
Nice.
That's it.
I remember that punch.
Remember,
Snake?
The feel of battle.
The clashing of bone and video.
Oh, yes.
I knew.
Hurt me more.
Do your thing.
Punch.
Kick.
Oh, that's good, Snake.
Oh, shoot.
I can shoot him now, right?
Where did he go?
One.
Dad.
Where did he go?
One.
Dad.
Oh, he's over here destroying all the chairs.
One.
Dad.
Yay!
I felt that, Snake.
Do you remember me now?
Can't be.
First try.
Yeah.
To have killed a Zanzibar.
I've gotten a little bit better at this game.
What?
Not again.
The
medicine.
What's happening?
Dropped plot line is what's happening, Snake.
I am losing myself.
So, essentially, for people, if you don't know...
Is it over?
There was going to be, like, a thing with...
I can't exactly remember what it was about, but, like, his whole freakouts were going to be a whole subplot.
And they had to drop it, so...
Um, but I guess the scenes stayed in.
Yeah, they had to cut it out.
Gray Fox.
Colonel, that ninja is Gray Fox.
No doubt about it.
Ridiculous.
The hurt?
You of all people should know he died in Zanzibar.
And Snake's voice there?
He should have died, but he didn't.
What?
Makes me so...
It happened before I joined Foxhound's medical staff.
They were using a soldier for their gene therapy experiments.
I never heard that.
Good actor.
It happened right after you retired.
David Hayter's amazing.
And predecessor, Dr. Clark, was in charge.
Dr. Clark?
Yes.
He started the gene therapy project.
Dr. Clark!
And where is he now?
Dead.
He was killed in an explosion in his lab two years ago.
So what about this soldier?
Apparently, for their test subject, they decided to use the body of a soldier who was recovered after the fall of Zanzibar.
Let's...
And that was Gray Fox.
Avoid a little bit.
But he was already dead.
Yes.
But they revived him.
They fitted him with a prototype exoskeleton and kept him drugged for four years while they experimented on him like a plaything.
Aww.
Today's genome soldiers were born from those experiments.
Gray Fox.
That's the sickest thing I ever heard.
They used him to test all sorts of gene therapy techniques.
I feel like this is an underrated soundtrack.
Naomi, why didn't you tell us about this sooner?
You know, track from the O.S.T.
Because it's confidential information.
That's really good.
Is that the only reason?
So sick.
Naomi.
What happened to Gray Fox?
It's sick.
The record says he died in the explosion.
I see.
But even if that ninja is Gray Fox, the question is, why?
Why?
From what I could tell, he didn't know who he was.
Are you saying that he's just a mindless robot?
No.
I'm not sure.
But he seems intent on fighting me to the death.
He remembered.
We'll meet again.
You snake?
I know it.
So you'll fight again?
Until you kill him?
I stopped at this point a while ago.
I don't want to spoil myself.
I'd rather not.
I gotta finish.
You snake?
But maybe that's what he wants.
But if you don't have time, you can always come back and watch me finish for you.
Thanks for hanging around.
Thank you.
Oh my God.
Here he comes.
How long are you going to stay in there?
Are you one of them?
Get out of there, you baby.
No, I'm not.
I always work alone.
Starting to get a...
Are you an otaku too?
Come on.
Get out.
He doesn't even entertain it.
You can't stay here forever.
Get out.
I'm starting to get a catapult.
I'm starting to get a caffeine headache, I think, from the coffee.
I didn't sleep much last night, which is why I got a coffee.
Your uniform is different than theirs.
I fell asleep at 5 AM, you guys.
You're the Metal Gear Chief Engineer, Hal Emmerich, right?
Yeah.
You know me?
I heard about you from Meryl.
Oh.
So you're here to rescue me.
Christopher Fritz.
Sorry, but no.
There's something that I've got to do first.
They changed his name.
Well, at least you're not one of them.
Oh.
You sad pathetic...
I'm okay.
I just twisted my ankle a little bit trying to get away.
Well, if that's all, it's nothing to worry about.
There was always Fritz in this.
I guess I never...
I want to ask you something.
I never noticed.
I need information about Metal Gear.
It's Jerma.
Oh my God.
Metal Gear?
That clip of him, Jerma.
Yeah.
What's Metal Gear really designed for?
Some of the VAs use aliens and stuff.
It's a mobile TMD.
It's designed to shoot down nuclear missiles, only for defensive purposes, of course.
Of course.
Fire!
Oh.
I already know that Metal Gear is nothing but a nuclear-equipped, walking death mafia.
Don't bully the nerd!
Nuclear?
What are you talking about?
The terrorists are planning to use Metal Gear to launch a nuclear missile.
Oh my God.
You're telling me you didn't know?
They're going to put a dismantled warhead into Metal Gear's TMD missile module?
Wrong.
From the beginning, the purpose of this exercise was to test Metal Gear's nuclear launch capability using a dummy nuclear warhead.
The terrorists are just continuing to work on it.
You started it!
No.
You're wrong.
He had no idea.
I heard it directly from your boss, Baker.
Little baby.
No.
A nuclear missile on Rex?
So you really didn't know.
No.
All the armament was built by a separate department.
And the president personally supervised the final assembly of the main unit.
President Baker?
Yeah.
I was never told exactly what they armed Rex with.
I only know it's equipped with a Vulcan cannon, a laser, and a railgun.
A railgun.
Kenneth, no.
Kenneth, yes.
A railgun, you said.
Yeah.
It uses magnets to fire bullets at extremely high velocities.
The technology was originally developed for the SDI system and later scrapped.
He even installed a PP gun on it.
Are you an otaku?
Yes, I am.
The railgun is on Rex's right arm.
Oh.
Metal Gear's main function is to launch nuclear missiles.
You sure you're not forgetting something?
Rex is so cute.
It's true that Metal Gear has a missile module on his back that can carry up to eight missiles, but are you saying it was originally meant to carry nuclear missiles?
They turned the Cephia filter up to 80 on this.
Cute?
Yes.
Rex is so cute.
Ray is cuter.
Yeah.
But that's not all I think.
I stand by that fact.
If Metal Gear fired only standard nuclear missiles, Call my opinion on base.
then they should already have all the practical data they need.
Oh my god, sassy snakes sitting there.
No.
Look at that.
Could it be?
Metal Gear's co-developer, Rivermore National Labs, was working on a new type of nuclear weapon.
They were using Nova and NIF laser nuclear fusion testing equipment and supercomputers.
So they developed a new type of nuclear weapon in a VR testing lab, huh?
Yes, but you can't use virtual data on a battlefield.
They would need actual launch.
Launch data.
These are some of the supercomputers.
If you link these, you can test everything in a virtual environment.
But it's all just theoretical.
So this exercise was designed to test the real thing.
Ray is a bit cooler than Rex.
What did our president do?
If the terrorists launched that thing...
Sassy.
The fifth snake is sassy snake.
Damn.
He's standing like a JoJo stand.
I'm such a fool.
It's all my fault.
Otacon, it's not your faaault.
Little baby.
You're just a little baby.
The truth is my grandfather was part of the Manhattan Project.
He suffered with a guilt for the rest of his life.
And my father is born on August 6th, 1945.
The day of the Hiroshima bomb.
I'm sorry, it's not funny, but it's just- it's just so goofy.
Oh my god.
Huey.
He was born... stupid.
This guy just wanted to make anime robots.
This guy wanted to make Gundams.
Gotta feel sorry about how he got played.
I know.
Every game...
Every game, Snake is having to tell Otacon to stop crying and pull himself together.
Play the I'm Nuclear song from MGS5.
If I don't start then their ballistic program is probably finished.
And since they haven't called for me in a few hours, they must not need me.
In other words, they must be ready to launch.
Merrill's got the detonation code override keys.
We'll link up with her.
If we can't override the launch, we'll have to destroy Rex.
He fell when he didn't go towards genetics to create Catgirls.
I mean...
I'll show you the way.
Look at this poor, sad guy.
On that leg of yours, you'll just slow me down.
You'll need me if you're gonna destroy Rex.
Otacon, you smell like piss.
Everyone will smell you from a mile away.
Please, use your brain.
I created Rex.
It's my right, my duty to destroy him.
No.
If you get a chance, try to escape.
When the coast is clear, I'll contact you by codec.
How am I supposed to escape from an island?
Swim!
Okay.
So what then?
I want you to hide somewhere and keep me informed.
You know this might be a good idea.
This place plays well, don't you?
Of course I do.
And don't worry.
I've got this.
Can I have this?
Can I have that?
It's the same stealth technology as the ninja.
Foxhound was gonna use them, but...
Can I have that?
With this, I'll be fine.
Bad leg and all.
Can I have that?
Good.
I want Meryl to watch after you, too.
Can I have that?
Meryl, the engineer's okay.
That's a relief.
I want you to look after him.
Do you hear it?
Where are you now?
Very close.
There she is!
Over there!
Oh no!
Damn, they've spotted me!
Meryl, what happened?
Something's wrong.
Did you hear something?
Wasn't that some kind of music?
Yeah, it was.
What did she look like?
Oh?
She... she was wearing the same green uniform as the terrorists.
Here we go.
Otacon being a little perv.
Yeah, what else?
A disguise?
She had such a cute way of walking.
She kind of wiggles her behind.
You were really looking.
Well, she's got a very cute behind.
Way of walking, huh?
Oh yeah.
Dude, thank you.
If she's disguised as the enemy, you'll have to contact her when she's alone, huh?
Ah, I see, I see.
There's only one place where we can be sure she's by herself.
Where's that?
Codec during after bosses.
Don't be so dense.
Yes, thank you.
Don't forget...
Don't feel like...
Um, don't...
Don't feel...
Here, use this security card.
Don't hesitate to remind me because I will forget because I just kind of like go through the game.
It's security level four.
Since I've played it, so...
Oh.
IBS, IBS, IBS, IBS!
You're not in pain, are you?
Oh my god, that made my controller fall.
You feel okay?
Nothing bothering you?
Why are you so...
Getting all friendly all of a sudden.
Why are you so close?
Nothing.
I'm glad you're okay.
You're strange.
I'm a little nervous.
Everyone else I've saved suddenly dies.
You're bad luck.
Forget it, doctor.
I love this interaction.
Call me Otacon.
Otacon?
It stands for Otaku Convention.
An otaku's a guy like me who likes Japanimation.
Japan was the first country to successfully make bipedal robots.
Call me Mintocon.
I also...
They're still the best in the field of robotics.
...like Japanimation.
And Japanese cartoons played some part in that?
They did.
Yeah!
I didn't get into science to make nuclear weapons, you know.
This is Policenauts, right?
I became a scientist because I wanted to make robots like the ones in the Japanese animes.
Yeah!
I like how they capitalize anime.
That just sounds like a childish excuse to me.
Yeah!
It's short for Mint Convention.
You're right.
We have to take responsibility.
Science has always thrived on war.
Greatest weapons of mass destruction were created by scientists who wanted to be famous.
But that's all over now.
They're not cartoons.
Snack.
I won't take part in murder anymore.
You're right.
Whatever.
All I want from you is information.
Sure.
I know everything about this whole thing.
Snack's like, I don't care about your ideals and your morals.
Ask me anything about Rex or about this place.
Also, with this stealth camouflage, I can sneak in and out of the armory and mess hall.
If this game was made today, he would be talking about me too, right?
If you need ammo or rations, just tell me and I'll bring them to you.
Yeah.
I'm on frequency 141.12.
Otacon would be a fan of Pekora.
See you later.
That's why he didn't create cat girls.
He wants bunny girls, you guys.
I'm on frequency 141.12.
Please not stream windmint, sometime.
Whenever I get around to it.
Yay!
Defeat ninja!
Yippie, yippie, yippie!
He wanted mech girls?
Based, based, based, based.
Take all the things we can get.
Ha.
I wish there was more ration.
All right.
It's not a phase, it's a lifestyle.
So true.
PlayStation!
But I actually, I don't know if you guys noticed, I'm playing...
Well, you guys saw that I'm playing the Master Collection, but I'm playing it on PC.
NiF was first announced in 95 and planned to finish building in 05, but budgeting issues pushed it back to 09.
NiF was ready by 05, like at MGS.
Ignition still wouldn't happen until 2017.
Wow.
Okay.
Now, we go.
Kind of looks like a Saturn.
It is a PlayStation though, right?
I mean, that would make sense, because this was for the PlayStation 1.
But it does... I can see the Saturn.
Right?
I can see it.
It does kind of look like a Saturn.
It does look like one.
It's so thick.
I had a PlayStation 1, but it was the thin one.
The Saturn was black.
Well, that looks darker, right?
Looks like a darker color.
So I can see how you would mistake it.
Oh.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, my gosh.
Bless you, Kojima, for your awesome camera angles.
Your cinematic...
God, it looks so...
It looks so... Oh, it's so scary.
Oh, my gosh.
Like, you come in.
Imagine you haven't walked into this room yet.
You walk in for the first time.
And...
And you, like, instead of...
Instead of, like, seeing what's going on, you, like, press against the door.
Oh, it's so good.
So awesome.
Cashmere is good.
He really likes movies.
He does.
Yes, he does.
He really likes movies.
You think I can...
Well, I don't want to use all my trap grenades right now.
I want the ration, though.
This one right there.
I want it.
What is in that box?
More Nikita missiles, maybe?
More ammo?
To the first floor.
And we gotta go see a cute little behind.
I'm wondering if I have time to...
Well...
I don't know if I have time to beat Psycho Mantis.
It really depends on how much I game.
And I don't trust myself.
I didn't make it so far, but...
I didn't make it very far, but...
I...
Did take an hour to watch some cutscenes.
To watch the briefings.
I think I'll save Psycho Mantis for...
Next week.
I think, maybe.
Oh, here comes the guy from the party.
Hello.
Good boy.
I'm going to the party room.
Psycho Mantis.
Yeah, that was me.
Oh my god.
That's so funny.
He's coming back.
He's got to pee.
Sorry.
I
got a reaction.
Lucky day.
Oh shit.
I've never heard her do the...
I've never heard her do that.
Oh my gosh.
We found her immediately.
That's crazy.
Hello, lady's room.
That was so easy.
Nothing here.
She's like...
She bested me.
Again.
That's the second time I've been able to sneak up on the legendary Solid Snake.
You're Meryl?
There's no way you could pass for a man for long.
What do you mean?
Hey, men aren't allowed in here.
I had no idea you were so feminine.
This is no time to try and hit on these snakes.
You horn dog.
I love it.
Just flirts with anything that moves.
Besides, it's a waste of time.
When I joined up, they gave me psychotherapy to destroy my interest in men.
Oh yeah, and that totally worked.
Same smart mouth.
You're Meryl, all right.
Yeah, it totally works against Solid Snake.
After all, I was disguised as a Genome Soldier.
So why'd you change?
You'd be a lot better off dressed like one of them.
I got tired of disguising myself.
This girl look pleased.
The truth is, the uniform smelled like blood.
The Foxhound tattoo.
What's that mark?
Huh?
Oh, this?
It's a paint tattoo.
It's not real.
I was a fan of Foxhound way back.
When guys like you and my uncle were in it.
Snake is different.
None of that gym therapy like there is today.
You guys were real heroes.
There are no heroes in war.
All the heroes I know are either dead or in prison.
One or the other.
But Snake, you're a hero, aren't you?
I'm just a man who's good at what he does.
Killing.
There's no winning or losing for a mercenary.
The only winners in war are the people.
That's right, and you fight for the people.
I've never fought for anyone but myself.
I've got no purpose in life.
No ultimate goal.
Come on.
It's only when I'm cheating death on the battlefield.
The only time I feel truly alive.
Seeing other people die makes you feel alive, huh?
You love war and don't want it to stop?
Is it the same with all great soldiers throughout history?
Why didn't you contact me?
My coat was broken.
Hand on the hip.
He's so sassy.
Shouldn't you just be happy we met up like this?
How did you recognize me in disguise?
I never forget a lady.
So there's something you like about me, huh?
Yeah.
You've got a great butt.
God, he's so honest.
Oh, I see.
First, it's my eyes.
Now, it's my butt.
And what's next?
On the battlefield, you never think about what's next.
Oh, my God.
Snake, you...
You!
So, Snake, how are the negotiations going?
No progress.
I don't know.
So it's all up to you, huh?
Living in the moment.
Somebody's got to stop them from launching a nuclear missile.
There are two ways.
Either we destroy Metal Gear or...
We override the detonation.
The music's so awesome.
You got the card keys from Baker?
Card keys?
Girl, you have pockets!
Where are the others?
There should be three keys.
You have pockets!
This is all I've got.
Where could the other two be?
I have no idea, but they must be somewhere.
If we can't find them, we'll have no choice but to destroy Metal Gear.
Uh-oh.
Okay, she's only got one.
That's fine.
Metal Gear is in an underground maintenance base to the north.
Take me, too.
I know this place better than you do.
You'll just slow me down.
You don't have enough battle experience.
I won't slow you down.
I promise.
And what if you do?
Then you can shoot me.
She says until we have to backtrack for...
I don't like to waste bullets.
She's like, I won't slow you down until we have to backtrack all the way back to the...
I'll be careful.
What in the building?
You know, I don't use makeup the way other women do.
Oh, it's her pick me moment.
Pick me, Meryl.
I hardly ever look at myself in the mirror.
You hate makeup.
I've always despised that kind of woman.
I always dreamed of becoming a soldier.
But I was wrong.
I'm not like other women.
Girls.
It wasn't really my dream.
My father.
He was killed in action when I was younger.
You wanted to follow in your father's footsteps?
Dead.
Not really.
I thought that if I became a soldier, I could understand him better.
So are you a soldier yet?
Wow.
I thought I was until today.
But now I understand.
She...
Truth is, I was just afraid of looking at myself.
She folded so quickly.
Afraid of having to make my own decisions in life.
She had one day.
I'm not going to lie to myself anymore.
It's time I...
One day here and she was like...
I want to know who I am.
What I'm capable of.
I want to know why I've lived the way I've lived until now.
I want to know.
Take a good look.
You won't get another chance for a while.
You should wash your face, too, while you're at it.
Yeah.
This isn't a training exercise.
Our lives are riding on this.
There are no heroes or heroines.
If you lose, you're worm food.
Yeah.
Worm.
Is that FAMAS functional?
Unfortunately, it's out of ammo.
Oh.
Where'd you get that Desert Eagle?
I found it in the armory.
It's a .50 caliber Action Express.
There was a SOCOM pistol, too, but I chose this.
We got the leftovers.
So I got a leftover, huh?
Isn't that gun a little big for a girl?
Hey.
Don't worry.
I can handle it.
She's more comfortable with it than a bra.
Mom, use my .45.
Listen.
I've used a gun like this since I was eight years old.
I'm more comfortable with it than I am with a bra.
Yeah.
If we're going to go to the north, we'll have to go through the countryside.
We can go to the commander's room on this floor.
The overland route is blocked by glaciers.
She and I just think the same way.
We're both girly pops, okay?
That's how I knew she was going to say that.
The door to the commander's room is security level 5.
This card will open it.
It was inside the pocket of the uniform I was wearing.
Oh my god!
Looks like he must have been guarding some place important.
You have pockets!
Okay.
Let's go.
She's just flaunting her perky boobs.
I know this place better than you.
She's just like...
I'll be point man.
Follow me.
She's just...
Oh.
She's just showing off how perky her chest is, you know?
And the music stopped.
I can keep up the music.
Stun grenade!
Good thing we didn't go in here earlier, right?
I didn't attempt to even get anything out of here.
Because I was like, oh, the guys are just going to disappear before we...
Before we move on, anyway.
What's under here?
I think I... I'm just looking for rations at this point.
Are you going to make Meryl blush?
Of course I'm going to make Meryl blush!
Of course!
That is Isabelle!
Night vision goggles!
You all can shut up.
You all can shut the hell up.
We got the night vision goggles.
You can all shut up.
We can all be quiet about the night vision goggles.
We do not need anything further.
Cardboard box B!
Oh.
It says...
This one is written...
Heliport.
Go to Heliport.
Would you rather be... Actually...
How do you pronounce that?
It's like Yuki.
Would you rather be friends with...
Paz, Quiet, Meryl, the boss, or Eva?
Probably...
Sunny.
And then this is probably to the nuclear warhead building.
As if I had to guess.
But, but, but... Thermal goggles!
But, but, but, but...
But, but, but...
Thermal goggles!
Thermal goggles, my beloved!
T-t-t-Thermal goggles.
What are they playing?
Video games?
Alright, let's go stare at her.
Let's go stare at a pretty lady.
I love staring at a pretty face.
What?
What is it?
Oh my god, she started to get red immediately.
Did you see that?
What are you staring at?
I can see it so clearly.
Clearly.
I never used to be able to see it that well, but now I can see it, like, happening.
Come on, Snake.
She's kidding.
What are you doing?
Silly boy.
What?
What is it?
Is this as red as it goes, or...
I think I remember her getting quite red.
What are you staring at?
Stop it.
Shy girl.
Come on, Snake.
She's so red.
She's folding.
I know.
All it takes is for Snake to, like, look at her...
Don't stare at me like that.
...saying nothing, and she just folds.
Man, he is so powerful.
What are you doing?
We've got to get a move on.
I had no idea Meryl was this much of a baddie.
No wonder I've seen so much fan art of her.
Oh!
I know, right?
She's...
What?
What is it?
Okay.
Look at her!
She's so red!
You're cute.
Why can't I go into the... I need a card to go to the bathroom?
Snake, what are you doing?
Let's go to the commander's room.
The commander will see you now, Mr. Foxhound.
You would also fold if Snake stared at you.
You're 100% correct.
I love this guy.
Oh my god!
Look at her!
What are you staring at?
She is a tomato over there!
My goodness.
Damn, Doki.
Okay.
If I save...
Will I have to like find her again?
Or where will it...
You know what?
Let's go to another... Can I go to another floor?
No, I can't.
Hmm...
If I save... It won't let me switch floors.
Snake, let's hurry up and go to the commander's room.
Okay.
Okay...
Do I have to do... Can I do Psycho Mantis in 30 minutes?
It also...
It is said that you are cute bot...
What?
We're not talking about me.
It will load up after meeting her.
Oh, okay great.
Then I'm gonna... Let's do some codex first.
And then I'll...
Colonel, your niece is fine.
Thank goodness.
For now.
You can't relax.
Not yet.
I know.
Yeah.
Talk about life.
Don't talk about his family like that.
Stop.
What are you planning to do to her?
Save her.
I'll explain afterwards.
I get it.
All the world's a stage and we're merely players, right?
Yes.
But even players can influence the play.
I just hope we can prevent it from having a bad ending.
Stop!
Stop pointing at me!
So, for those who don't know, there is an option to save the animals or kill the animals.
You can save Meryl or you can kill Meryl.
It's in a scene coming up-ish.
A little ways away.
Coming up after the next two bosses.
But if you save her and if you kill her, it's two different endings.
I will be saving her because it's the canon ending and since I'll be playing through all the games, I want to do the canon ending so that it matches with the timeline of what I'll be playing.
So that's my thought process with it.
Just like Super Metroid.
Exactly.
What do you mean canon in quotes?
But if you're interested in the other ending, we totally did it in Twin Snakes so you can go watch it there.
Master!
You managed to link up with Meryl.
Good.
Stop calling me cute.
So now you must have the card keys that will override the detonation code.
You should hurry.
The time limit is running out.
Okay, Master.
I'll do it for you.
I'll do it for you, Master.
What do I call Meryl?
No response.
Come on, pick up.
Pick up, Meryl.
She's like looking at me like, hey, let's get a move on, buddy.
You found Meryl.
I forgot how to say hello.
Matara taught me how to say hello in Russian.
If I heard it, I would know it, I think.
Oh!
Privyet!
Yes!
Yeah!
I remember.
Well, because you guys typed it.
Thank you for running this event and working towards solving hyper-cancer.
Please put this towards saving the animal.
Can I get a hype?
You mean to stop?
Stop it!
Okay, let's talk to Mayling.
It's a good thing you hooked up with Meryl.
You should have seen the Colonel.
He doesn't like to let it show because he's the boss, but he was so happy he could barely contain himself.
I'm glad to hear that.
Save.
Okay, guys.
Next week we're starting with Psycho Mantis.
Oh my goodness gracious.
I don't know if I will Endurance to the end.
I still have quite a ways away.
I'm not even halfway through the game.
What would be halfway through the game?
Hmm...
Kindy, maybe?
Greetings from Germany.
Psycho Mantis is halfway, maybe?
When it tells you to insert disc 2?
No, no.
That's further...
That's further down, I believe.
Yeah.
Raven is near the end.
Yeah, Raven is the last boss fight.
Before...
Rex.
Sorry, spoilers.
For people.
I'm just trying to think.
God see you back in good form.
Good luck on Mantis next week.
Thank you!
I just... I have...
Like I said, I didn't...
I didn't sleep...
I went to bed at like 5 am.
I get a delayed jet lag.
So when I first come back from Japan, I'm usually fine for the first couple of days.
And then after a couple of days, I can't go to sleep until 4 or 5 am.
But I still wake up at 10 am.
I mean, it's still 5 hours of sleep, which isn't bad.
But if I'm recovering from sick, I don't want to push it too much.
But...
Yeah, I guess maybe...
the hind D would be halfway.
Probably.
Thank you.
I wish this could go all night.
Well, maybe next time we will go all night.
I might just get so into it.
I might just be like...
I'm gonna go forever!
So, yeah.
But yeah, have fun watching.
If anybody's watching Doki, have fun watching her tonight.
And also the debuts, the next Hololive debuts, the Justice debuts, I wanted to be watching.
I didn't realize... I thought they were Saturday, Sunday.
I didn't realize it was yesterday.
But...
But we had already made our schedule before it was announced.
So I was just like...
Afterwards, I was like...
I didn't realize.
So, whoopsie.
But...
Yeah.
Exciting weekend.
Thanks for kicking off Metal Gear with me.
Hopefully I didn't do so poorly.
Putting my incentive to school 666 right.
Okay.
We'll see.
I might have to...
I mean, I don't think the game is out yet.
But we also might need some time to grow additional brain cells anyway.
Spank, thanks for the 10 gift and thank you!
Thank you!
But yeah, so...
Always fun watching people play games they love.
Yeah, maybe next week we might endurance it.
Who knows?
I might be tired because I have a pretty busy week next week.
But I'll talk about that later.
And yeah!
Metal Gear!
I'm nervous about Psycho Mantis.
But I handled the other bosses pretty well, so...
Maybe I'll...
Maybe my gamer skills have improved.
Thanks to Master Miller.
Use your instincts as a gamer!
So...
You know, maybe... I don't know.
Maybe Metal Gear Rex won't take me so long.
I seem to have like a brief recollection of taking the longest time with Rex, but we'll see.
I think I've improved as a gamer a little bit.
Your skills have improved?
You were quite fast though.
Yeah, I think so.
Thank you everybody!
Thank you!
I'm gonna go eat.
I'm hungry, hungry, hungry.
I'm a hungry ghost.
And you guys should as well.
And enjoy the rest of your Saturday!
Or if it's Sunday for you, get some rest.
What are you doing?
Still awake?
Good night!
Master!
Bye bye!
See you guys tomorrow for more Doom!
Thank you guys!
Thank you so much!
Thanks for letting me indulge in my brain rot a little bit more.
Bye bye!
I just realized I didn't let Mei Ling finish like speaking.
But all she said was talk to you later, Snake.
She didn't give me a proverb or anything.
I think she hates me.
Mei Ling hates me!
She hates me!
Mei Ling hates me, you guys!
Mei Ling hates me!
Oh my god, she hates me!
No!